what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos guys as you already know if
you have watched two or more of my lives
and you do not subscribe we have beef
while you're at it make sure you like
the video on your way in as that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams a couple
announcements before we start the show
um the first is that we have two clips
channels the first is Pearl daily and
the second is just pearly Clips make
sure you guys go subscribe to both also
guys we have four membership tiers the
first tier lets you be a part of the
live chat the second tier gets you to be
a part of the Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs I know I've been promising
you guys this forever but I swear we're
doing a penthouse tour soon
um third tier you get to connect with us
on social media and the fourth tier you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month guys I have gotten over 75 million
views this month if you want to know how
I do it I would strongly suggest signing
up for the one-on-one social media
coaching session other times people just
ask me about the show or you know
whatever you want to pick my brain about
for 30 minutes
um also guys go follow my Instagram it's
just just dot pearly things and make
sure you put in the whole thing because
I am Shadow banned on Instagram and go
follow my Tick Tock it's just
pearlythings dot five and six as you
know they banned me on my first second
and third and fourth account so make
sure you go follow my fifth and sixth
also guys we have a sponsor today so a
major airline has privacy rights
activists disappointed after a recent
data breach turned out to be a gold mine
for hackers this affected customers and
employees of the airline as they had
their social security numbers driver's
license numbers and other personal
personally identifiable information
stolen in a matter of days several other
airlines in recent years have had
similar data breaches making me wonder
if my data has ever been stolen as well
that is why I signed up for with virtual
Shield one virtual Shield ones identity
protection feature scan 700 billion data
elements for suspicious activity
associated with your name bank account
number and other personified personable
personally identifiable information its
detection system will alert you in real
time via call text or email if there's
ever a data breach associated with your
information it also comes with unlimited
VPN access and advanced VPN plus
features including malware and ad
blocking hundreds of thousands of
Internet users trust virtual Shield one
to help protect their identity imagine
the Peace of Mind you'll have knowing
virtual Shield ones helping protect your
identity behind the scenes try virtual
Shield ones risk free for 30 days by
clicking the link in the description box
below after entering your details you
have you'll have instantaneous access to
all Security benefits virtual Shield one
offers this offers time sensitive so
hurry up and get it now okay so today's
topic is
what should women bring to the table a
lot of times I hear women talking about
how they are the table
and for some reason men are not
satisfied with this answer
so today I decided we should do a deep
dive in what women should bring but
before I start we have a lovely panel
today so why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting here going around and then
second row
my name is Ali I have a YouTube channel
at real film Sapien I am 27 years old
and I am married uh fun show him the
ring oh
yeah uh thank you and my pinky toes are
both sideways
so that's my fun fact there you go I
didn't even know that we're friends
good I would think guys
uh I'm your host Rob I'm a presenter I'm
35 and I'm I'm married as of one year
one year officially married for myself
um fun fact about me I fell asleep in a
skip before so not great
hi guys I'm Kane I'm 26.
um I'm a music artist and entrepreneur
and a fun fact about me is I have a
first class degree in business and
finance
go ahead me yeah all right cool so my
name is who is Kai second appearance on
this channel
um I'm 28 fun facts about me is that I
have a YouTube channel um and I have a
freestyle show
I'm hussam I'm 25 and I'm single fun
fact about me I used to be a police
officer
um my name is Joseph 30 years old single
fun fact about me is I have a YouTube
channel called a matter of mindset
I'm Alex
um I'm 35 I'm single
I also uh run a YouTube channel it's
only a few months old it's called 100
and it's about uh similar to the
discussion we're gonna have today based
on what I've seen on this channel before
uh it's about what people really think
so go and check that out 100 on YouTube
Stephen 28 work in finance
main thing about me is a design that
ready to wear clothing mainly menswear a
little bit of female pieces
um but yeah that's that's me 28.
yeah that's me okay so
thank you guys all for coming so today
um I have my Hefty Duffy whiteboard out
and I specifically recruited men for
this show because I want to hear from
the men
what do you guys want from women what
should women that come to you bring to
the table so I'm gonna get up
and you can start
for me personally it's more about a
degree of
personality traits alongside Beauty I
think the things what people have uh
what women think matter to Men actually
don't we don't care about your money we
don't care that you're independent we
don't care you are a quote unquote boss
[ __ ] like no one cares about any of
that things especially if you want
something seriously I think the biggest
thing they don't understand is that
the to get a man to commit to you and to
get a man to sleep with you is different
and those qualities are different so if
a guy is just looking to sleep with a
woman
um certain long-term things he won't be
interested in
um so for me I would say
why what women need to bring or what I
would like them to bring per se is sort
of feminine energy submissive
non-argumentative
um kind
supportive these are the traits are
important to me anyway
foreign
for me personally I'd say
I would like in a serious relationship a
woman to bring loyalty is a big one for
me
um
and I'd also say
apart from loyalty another big one would
be
about to be virtuous
I'd say
but to be virtuous and what do you mean
by virtuous virtuous is
is not
in the sense of almost like a
that kind of
innocent feminine energy and
unwillingness to kind of
take leadership are you are you
Christian uh no I wouldn't cross myself
have you heard of Proverbs 31
I've heard of it I don't know what it is
that's why it's describing the ideal
wife I think it's proverbs 31 is
probably the best example of a virtuous
woman but it's a it's intimidating yes
but yeah that's what women should strive
to be I would agree with you
yeah
so me do you do you date hoes
I knew it was coming I'm sorry
so me what I would like my woman to
bring to the table is loyalty I would
need my my woman to be my friend because
I don't just want to be with someone
that's not that I don't get along with
and again like she would need to be
beautiful in a sense because I don't
just want to be looking at you and like
you don't like I'm not attracted to you
so that would be for me
well for me definitely you'd have to be
a virgin so virginity is the main thing
I'd say come you're born with value
don't give it away if you want the guy
to full on marry devote you and make you
his one and only don't give away what
makes you valuable to men you're born
with a certain amount of value based on
your looks based on your purity
but even sometimes based on your family
status sometimes you're from a wealthy
family well-known family there's a lot
of things that go into it but yeah I'd
say the main things are definitely
submission you want you don't want
someone to argue against you you don't
want someone to be against you you want
to be the leader of your house you want
to be the leader of the relationship and
in order to do that you need someone
submissive loyalty is definitely there
because if she's not loyal no one's
going to be interested in her in the
first place unless you're you know a car
core a simple you know there's loads of
words to describe feminine definitely
because you know it's just you can't be
masculine and expect a masculine man
because a masculine man is going to want
someone feminine you can't be because
it's the same way of describing a man
who's part feminine and like one day he
wants to wear a mini skirt or a dress
that's not very masculine is it it's
like a woman saying oh yeah I'm gonna
wear the trousers and go to work today
it's just like that's not feminine it's
just it's not what men want
men literally want feminine loyalty
submission Purity Beauty as well like
some men don't even expect that much
Beauty anymore they've actually got lots
as long as you're hitting the other
targets they're actually fine with
lowering what they perceive as their
level
as long as you hit everything else that
they want so that's what I'd say they
should actually bring to the table what
they've already got what they're born
with and then character traits that they
just develop over time if they're
actually following what they should be
following
um I want a woman that's Cooperative
again no one likes to argue all day
um a woman that's submissive
um she knows that I'm not being not
asking her to be submissive is not
against her it's all that everything
runs smoothly
um a woman as a team player that
understands that everything is for the
betterment of the collective not for
anyone's selfish interests and the woman
that's supportive kind
yeah that's that's about it
well uh if I'm just looking for a good
time then
none of what anyone here is
um apart from you know you gotta look
good of course
but if it's um someone I'm gonna take
seriously
um you have to just not get in the way
of my work
you've got to
add
to my work ethic as in whatever you can
do whatever holes you can feel that I
may have that can help me
um do what I do better
uh you know help me in my kind of
my strive for more
my ambition
so just get behind me and support me
and be loyal
be in shape
and if you're not in shape then you must
have that
um as a goal you must be actively right
now be looking to get into shape
and
yeah just be you know just just be cool
like
you know all that loudness and rare
tattoo none of that just
be cool be feminine
are there any skills that you'd like
like what specific skills would you like
a girl to have
but it's cook would be nice okay what
what do you think girls should be able
to cook
um I don't think pasta counts I'm gonna
start I think everyone is like I said I
wanna I wanna be wifey like what what
should she what should she start with
what did she learn to cook uh cultural
food so depending on what ethnicity she
is I think she should at least know the
basic the basic foods that our culture
comes from if I'm with someone Arab I
expect them for example Moroccan I
expected tonight to make tagine I expect
it's an hour to make the basic things
that come from that side of the world
I'm sure if I'm American I should know
hamburgers and hot dogs
there's brisket that's barbecue I've
seen American barbecue I know they're
like I'm sure like I know I know some
Jamaican guys that's like if my wife
can't make rice and peas I'm not even
gonna look at her so this is you know
it's just you need to be able to provide
the sustenance side and like the
nurturing side so you need to be able to
cook you need to be able to clean
because that is the main thing you're
going to be doing it's like you're going
to be taking care of children
skills what cleaning skills would you
want you get to build a wife today
want to get specific because a lot of
times when I hear what guys want from
girls it's very Broad and there's no
like specific things that girls can do
to like train to do these things and we
are opening a wife school soon so oh
well I think the reason sorry the reason
why there's no specific things is
because if there were those girls would
not give a [ __ ] anyway okay
well today we're doing a whiteboard no
we'll care if we're into you well I mean
there's women that they find themselves
like surprised they're you know turning
out their feminine side I guess for the
right guy they find themselves on Google
looking up how to make French toast so
so it happens but I think yeah there has
to be genuine desire so if a woman if a
woman is just giving you a hard time
about the things that you like well she
can kind of just keep it pushing I think
that's a fair point and the ability to
learn as well even if you don't know how
to do anything the ability to learn to
show is how I personally would receive
care I would that to me that would show
you that you care about what I think
what I like to do what I like to eat Etc
and they're building to learn is half
the battle but with the attitude of oh I
don't want to do that why should I do
that it's it's just redundant isn't it
yeah yeah that's how I got married I
didn't know how to do anything any I
have no no model of like how to be a
wife but I brought a willingness to
learn and so I think that that just
happened to be enough well with results
because I feel like I feel like if I was
slipping up people say something so I
think it really just comes down to the
basics of knowing how to keep a house so
if the man's actually going out working
working his ass off trying to provide
for the family I think that it's the
women's actual duty to make sure the
house is clean the kids are taken care
of he doesn't want to come home to
everyone screaming he wants like the
house to be peace he wants to come home
to peace from chaos work is sometimes
chaos I describe work it's chaos
sometimes so he's going to come from
chaos into Peace So the whole point is
everything needs to be kept dinner ready
and that's it it's it's not that
difficult like I'd say that when you
talk about cleaning skills I'd say just
like mop mop the floor make it so that
when you enter the house you take off
your shoes so the house stays clean like
everyone people in the house makes try
their hardest to make sure it doesn't
get any dirtier but obviously the wife's
job is to clean if it does get any dirty
so dusting just mopping you know vacuum
cleaner yeah even get a Roomba it does
half the job you're up for you but at
the end of the day the whole point is
you just want to come home to a nice
clean nice smelling house and I think to
add on to the the Peace point that you
made I think a woman should be like your
spiritual protector in a sense like
you'll have physical protector I feel
like she needs to be able to like Spirit
spiritually protect you and ground you
because the world is almost can be
chaotic and when you come home you want
her to be able to ground you and you
want her to be able to make you feel at
peace if that makes sense and that goes
back to our point about we don't want
someone argumentative yeah destructive
those things don't bring peace and
ironically what happens is if you are
with a woman like that and she behaves
like that that's just in all honesty it
just gives a man more reason to cheat
because he's just gonna go somewhere and
build up peace understanding you know
good listening skills from another woman
and she's going to take your place so
how how can a woman keep you grounded
because I think I think I struggle with
that I think I mean my husband comes
home he can be pretty stressed out from
work because like you said work is chaos
so I'm like well like what do I do do I
hug him do I leave him alone I think
he's the leave him alone give uh let him
play video games kind of Route so like
how can a woman be grounding to you guys
what's what would peace look like she
could do it oh okay it's not simple it
just comes down to silence and then just
doing the things that she normally would
do for you taking care of you sitting
next to you like just you know peace
peace generally is seen as silence if
you're in peace if you're in you know
people say Zen it is pure silence the
guy wants to come home to a nice quiet
home most of the time he doesn't want to
come home to chaos peace is normally
described as silence okay
that for me I think the Deep obviously
loyally and cooperative and
the friend and feminine are all key
things but I think the most important
thing is deep understanding now there's
levels of understanding and I think with
understanding comes trust so if you get
to know the man and you really want to
fulfill your man and want to see him win
then you're going to let him lead and I
think a lot of it boils down to trust
there's a lot of people saying oh I love
my man I love my man
but for one reason or the other they're
the biggest holdback sometimes so I
think that men I think men realize when
a girl genuinely
wants to see him win not just for her
benefit and for me I think that's the
that's the key thing and with that when
a female's trusting you comes femininity
a lot of men are thinking oh why is my
girl masculine because she's not trusted
you so I think that's what I think
that's what it boils down to so I hear
that I hear where you say it you wanna
you wanna come home and you want silence
and peace
but now if she's silent it could be a
bit of a problem she can talk about it
well that's what I was saying is like
what if you're coming home and uh you're
stressed or you're feeling down what if
you wanna like you want I know something
encouraging what would that look like
because one of my girlfriends has told
me that when her man is stressed out
that she just gives him a big hug so I
think I was looking for like those kind
of actions obviously you know being
quiet in the midst of chaos is helpful
that's what I think too because a lot of
times when guys say what they want it it
sounds really simple which okay and but
it's very Broad and so it's like if you
were gonna say to someone all right I
want to be a wife how do I become one
like what would you tell them to do go
ahead let me is it Aliyah oh yes so I
can't speak for all men I can't speak
for your your husband however
I can tell you about me so if I came
back from work and I was stressed
all my other half would have to do
if I had one would be
nothing
like silence
chill
okay
um
there's not even that much pressure on
you to to
um
yeah like just have something ready for
us to eat together
yeah
um and then just chill
let me you don't need to ground me or
anything like that like I've been
grouting myself for 35 years I'm very
very good at grounding myself and all
the rest of it just don't don't add to
the stress yeah that's that's it okay
that's an action a lot of girls a lot of
girls I'm not saying all girls a lot of
girls somehow still find a way to just
not be able to do nothing they they find
a way to want to add to the stress it's
like they've been waiting for you to
come home all day just to tell you
something you have to get on your nerves
you know sometimes it's like all right a
man's just happy just to see you like
just just be just exist and be feminine
so I can give you my full masculine like
if you're acting frantic and all
masculine how can you expect me to be
masculine well you know it's not it's
not like that so like I stay home um and
then so my husband's gone like 10 to 12
hours a day and you know when I see him
I just get so excited I'm like oh my God
I can't wait to tell you about my day
and he's like 30 minutes an hour 30
minutes an hour and I'm ready to hear
about your day so like we don't we don't
we're not trying to add to your plate
but I see your point so it's called a
decompression time is what a lot of
counselors call it apparently men need
that I feel like I don't think women are
like that I don't feel like I need not
even like five minutes to myself no
because we're more social so to us like
when we come home we're excited to talk
to each other but men aren't like that
they're like Get Away have you ever seen
that have you ever seen that Chris Rock
I think it's Chris Rock where he's like
we like you there but not there okay
I want I want to be with you but you
know I don't really I want to be around
you so you could just be in the air vent
that's what Patrice O'Neill said oh God
I was going to say I think as men
I think we're very self-aware in the
sense that how we want to make sure that
we receive our woman properly so
sometimes we may need like half an hour
to just to decompress but I think
sometimes women take offense to that
when they say give me like 30 minutes
why are you mad at me
and it's like it's not about you babe
it's me just give me 30 minutes that's a
hard concept for them to grab that it's
not about them because they always think
it's about them but that's why you get
guys sort of sitting in the car when
they get back from work 10 minutes just
to have a moment to themselves to go
into the house because hey it's like you
know I don't mean this disrespectfully
but you know when you have a puppy and
they run to the door when you come
through the door it's a bit like that
it's nice it's nice it's not supposed to
be of course disrespectful but it's like
the excitement to see you it is lovely
but like you said you need to just five
minutes just let me just chill for two
seconds I mean I'd actually also add it
it depends on your current like position
in the relationship so what what like if
you're in the honeymoon period I'd say
it's a lot more romantic and full-on and
more sexually driven at that point in
the first like six months of normal
relationships a lot of sex happens so in
that case the man would be anticipating
that as soon as he gets home if I was
married I'd expect some form of intimacy
as soon as I get home if it was the
first but obviously let's say 10 years
down the line if I'm working and if
things are chaotic where can I get home
I'm just going to want to relax I'm just
going to want to sit decompress as
you've said and then eventually after a
while maybe have dinner and then during
dinner start conversation and then keep
a conversation going overnight but the
whole point is you need men need that
decompression when they get home if
they're not because the thing is men the
thing is if it's not the honeymoon
period and it's not a part where he's
very sexually driven and he can't wait
to get home to literally rail you
against the bed then you literally need
the position off he needs peace he needs
to relax for a bit because if he doesn't
get that he's just gonna build up even
more stress and it's going to get
bottled then he might explode and even
and some men explode in different ways
and then yeah I'd say that's the main
that's the Crux of the situation yeah I
think I think the main thing I can speak
for all men I think all men want respect
definitely it was I think it boils down
to respect when a man is disrespected he
can do crazy things let's be honest oh
man I think disrespect even leads men to
cheating which never really wants to get
spoken about it's always this guy's a
bad guy for cheating but let's ask
ourselves how many times how many times
did you disrespect your man before he
cheated that's like every single like
school shooter story I've ever heard
yeah I mean we we want respect from men
let alone our women do you know what I
mean like respect is number one be
Beyond love beyond beyond anything
respect is one and then well a woman has
to respect you in order to love you in
the first place it starts with respect I
think without respect it doesn't work it
cannot work if the girl actually wants
she's gonna have to get to the point
where she has to respect you or she has
to find someone she does respect yeah
the relationship doesn't work without
respect otherwise you get a lot of
problems just developing and actually
growing it's like a seed if you if
there's no respect it's gonna grow yeah
it's gonna literally grow and ruin
things and it gets ruined in different
ways so you guys you guys know why we
disrespect you guys right okay this
looks like for the for the women that
love you that get out of pocket okay
because there's just like some naturally
psychotic women that's like she's just
gonna be out of pocket for everyone so
the way uh there's a doctor his name is
Dr egrets he talks about love and
respect right and it's in the Bible too
where women are commanded to respect
their husbands and husbands are
commanded to love their wives right and
there's a reason for that and so when
when I feel unloved we tend to get
disrespectful and then if you feel like
I'm disrespecting you you're gonna go
out of your way to make sure that I
don't feel loved and you're not gonna
cuddle with me and it goes into this
cycle and you never know when to hop off
because it's like well do I want to hop
off no he should hop off when really
it's like once you know you're in the
cycle you should just hop off just for
the greater good whoever figures it out
first so yeah I think that that's a
that's a common thing because um when
men blow up nobody ever asks what did
she say and I feel like we should start
asking because it's really bad because
they always if if a girl blows up it's
what did he do yeah yeah but we never
asked what did she say so many times
that one oh well what did you do what
did you do it's not about me I'm not a
narcissist it's about it's true we have
to and we have to remember as well is
respect isn't just in the home when
we're outside your females representing
you she's representing you in a mad way
she's not respecting you so I think it's
such a 360 thing yeah you've got like
obviously when you come home from work
but on the flip side you've got how
she's representing you outside if she if
your girl does not respect and rate you
you hear him know about it and it will
burn but girl a girl asked me the other
day ago that I'm talking to and um she
said to me
um so babes like how would you want me
to be like say we were a thing like I
would you know and I said to uh I want
you to pretend you're always wearing a
permanent T-shirt with my face on it so
you know no matter where you are you
you're wearing a t-shirt and it's got my
face on it
and and that's the mindset that you need
to have because when they've when
they've got that in their mind
they're acting it out there's no it's
like a constant romance yeah exactly
what are some ways that a woman can
demonstrate respect because again like
respect very Broad and we ain't got no
doubt he's just like y'all don't got
daddies so what how can we demonstrate
by listening just look out in there I do
think that like a good woman's gonna
test you as a man I don't think there
should be like an unrealist unrealistic
expectation that a woman's not going to
test you and it's good because as a man
you need to be on your A game so a good
woman's gonna test you and you need to
be like the best version of yourself to
be able to deal with that and kind of
make her fit into your frame just to add
that in I have to disagree with that one
uh yeah I was gonna say I completely
disagree I think respect is when she
doesn't do that like she respects you
should disrespect you by the way no no
I'm saying like she shouldn't even test
you like the whole point is when someone
respects you you don't like you don't
test your boss you don't go to your boss
and start testing them [ __ ] testing them
like oh what about this what about that
like at the end of the day it is the
kind of Boss Dynamic like at the end of
the day a relationship is you go to work
every day like I've just like it's just
it's really simple it sounds it's people
complicate it a lot but when it comes to
respect just listen to what the man says
at the end of the day he has the final
say if you're in a dynamic relationship
where it's masculine feminine the man
has the final say and the Crux of it
really does literally come down to
listening respect not arguing
understanding that he has the final say
and that's literally how it should be so
to boil it down
she has to listen yeah listen that's
actionable items whatever the man says
does do so she listens yeah yeah okay
and you know what not to not to
disrespect my brother here or anybody
else on the panel but no tests yeah
because I'm really this is going to be
the action items you might be you might
be right but in my in my world it's not
unrealistic because listen I'm tested
every day yeah up at 6am working from
eight till nine most days seven days a
week no tests that's enough if you test
to become part of the problem I I don't
I don't think I don't think I know a
single wife that doesn't test their
husband now I think there are malicious
ways to test your husband I think that's
true but there's other ways that you're
going to be tested so like example you
know fatherhood that's that's a test is
to see like you know how do you perform
as a father and a husband I don't think
you're going to be able to get away from
it and so I live in the Midwest and so
there's a feminine wise masculine
husbands in the church husbands are
providers protectors women are feminine
submissive but there there are still
going to be tests like you still want
your boundaries respected as a human
being and an individual I I understand
what you're saying like don't be
malicious about it but I think it's
unrealistic to think that you know that
it's not going to happen at all so I'm
thinking I'm just going with that train
of thought I don't I don't really have
an opinion on this but I'm going with
that train of thought do employees test
bosses ever
yes they do because you kind of see what
you can get away with right I'm thinking
more [ __ ] test like do something
disrespect like there's respectful ways
of testing there's passive ways of
testing like for example you brought up
the have children that's a passive way
that's gonna happen that's not you can
see that and it's not a direct test to
the man it's just like the man's gonna
provide and you're gonna see what he's
like how he's going to take care of the
child how he's going to take care of you
so a question should and this is just
genuine question should a woman if you
tell her something and it's not
something that she agrees with how
should she go about it because at some
point there's going to be something that
you tell her that she disagrees with and
asked me an example otherwise because
there's so many different things that
would be so
um
oh you got one I have one so you and
this is something common that I've I
don't like older Generations you want to
buy a house
she thinks you're being too Reckless
with the money
she gets absolutely zero so zero say
zero say when the man has earned all
that money and she is it depends on the
dynamic if the man is the only one
working and providing then he she gets
absolutely zero so because it's the
man's money and he's providing you a
house you it's like Beggars can't be
choosers right I know that's the wrong
technology most girls have to work in
2022. I'm talking about Dynamic with a
man dot where the woman doesn't work
obviously if the woman 2022 so most
girls have to work like she has to help
pay the mortgage my my opinion no I
don't really have an opinion I'm just
trying to figure out because in that
case I wouldn't I wouldn't like be happy
with that at all but if someone was in a
situation where the woman was also
earning and she was also contributing
then definitely however much I believe
it should be very static so however much
he contributes is how much say she has
so if the man earns 70 and she earns 30
I believe she should have a 30 Say by
that logic if a girl earns more than a
guy she should have the final say yes
but I also don't agree with the woman
working if it wants to be a dynamic
office the man and woman in a masculine
feminine okay well yeah I mean that's
the ideal right I think most girls would
like to be Housewives but again we're in
2022. I think lower the standards I
think living standards okay go ahead the
key thing is yeah you're we're 2022
granted to 2023. We Can't be we've got
to always look at it and I think just
looking at like the no tests
feel like genuine like generally
if the female has the respect levels
that she should have for you and she's
going for the type of man
that she a genuine King then the testing
is not really going to happen and going
on to that the the split so talking
about like the property with things
if if the female's earning of course it
makes sense to communicate on on the
twist to say that ah do you know what
I'm gonna make a choice you're gonna
have problems in 10 years and she's just
gonna bottle things up you're asking for
a problem it's about genuinely you have
to
communicate well with each other hear
each other's voice
and because it's different now what
percentage where the man's earning all
of the money is is it's not really
happening like that females generally
are working they're earning money
they're doing projects however she can
be earning the same amount but if she
really has trust in you she's going to
let you naturally lead with a decision
the problem is there's a lot of men
earning the same or a little bit less
than the female of course the female's
not going to trust the man because a lot
of these a lot of these males out here I
don't even trust them myself so like
they can't they can't manage their own
money in that Dynamic the woman actually
has more so because that woman normally
is in control of the sex in the marriage
and if the man doesn't do what she wants
she's gonna it's gonna become a secless
marriage but then she's the she's the
masculine one yeah that's what happened
that's what happened yeah she deserves
that I can't I can't speak yeah that's
why I personally wouldn't want someone
who's working I would want my wife to be
a full-on stay-at-home wife so and
that's how I avoid that that situation
that you just brought up uh what if
she's working and then she wants to
contribute and then she gets to say in
my opinion it should be the man's the
only one dealing with the money and
financial side it's just it's just like
nowadays it's idealistic you know what I
think the whole idea of there being no
test sounds great but the purpose of a
test is to prove how competent someone
is so if she's constantly testing you
she's trying to show how competent you
are and let's be honest you can never
you can never get too comfortable so I
think passive testing is good but I
don't think direct testing is good at
all yeah I think I think it's intent
like what's your intent is it to make
your man feel small or is it to be like
okay how is this leadership because I
mean I I'm a self-aware woman I don't
again I don't know a single wife that
wasn't that doesn't test her man but
mine is the only the only ish test that
I have left that I even do and it I
think at this point in time I like I
think it might just be out of habit but
the one thing I'll do is like I'll be
thinking in my head I'm like ah I want a
glass of water but I don't want to get
out of bed I'm like okay all right let
me see if he's gonna say yes because he
might he might not and so I'll ask my
husband like hey can you give me a glass
of water and sometimes he'll look at me
for like three to five seconds and he's
like I kind of I think you can get that
yourself and I'm like okay this man
knows I'm capping he knows I'm capping
yeah yeah but it's good because if you
can fold to me you'll fold to the world
exactly right so I just I need to know
that you can stand up to me because I'm
not always going to be able to leave
myself like women I I'm gonna like
confess it yeah like we're emotional and
we're hormonal in many ways and so like
if we're because I'm also pregnant right
now and so that first trimester I'm like
I need a man to guide me because I don't
know where I'm taking myself at this
point in time but you guys were talking
about the house that actually happened
to me
um my my husband he fell in love with
the house and he's very much if you find
something he likes that's what he's
gonna get and I was worried about it
because it was a little bit it was a
little bit expensive okay uh and so I
mean he did ask for my input though but
I do give the the big life decisions I
just give it to my husband because I
don't I don't want that responsibility
on my shoulders I'm just being real but
um so we just looked at it and it was a
risk and I was like well do you think
that you know we can pull it off because
I know that my husband's also willing to
have accountability for a negative
outcome and he's like yeah well it's a
risk but I think we can swing it I think
we can pull it off and at the end of the
day we did end up uh being able to do it
so he he guessed right and nothing bad
happened and for women that are watching
even if your man fails sometimes he's a
human being like he's not going to get
100 right all the time you gotta at
least be nice about it as wives like we
make mistakes too often often probably
more but I don't think it's difficult
um you get as a wife you get a lot of
benefit of his decision so that's why he
takes a risk of doing the bigger
decision because I can't for me I can't
if I followed everything my wife did I'd
be in debt I couldn't afford I'd be in
situations like I'd be in this like that
but it's up to me to say no I'm gonna do
what's best for us and you're and you're
just gonna have to get on board because
whatever you do like you said about the
money if he's buying a house he's not
living in there by himself like he's
living in there with his wife his
children so it's only going to benefit
them so it's like when we speak about
money in general if a man earns more
money than a woman usually the woman
gets all the benefit of that and that's
not a negative thing he actually puts
you in a better position his way of
thinking is that if I can work harder
and make more money she might not have
to work as much she might not have to
work at all she could be at home with
our kids it's all in the benefit of your
of your significant other right but if
we to flip it and women are like oh I'm
gonna earn all this money now they think
okay I don't need someone because I earn
this money so it never benefits the man
so whenever we have a conversation about
money of oh I earn a certain amount of
money as a woman and that fact is into
their attraction it doesn't because it
doesn't benefit the man the same way a
man who with that amount of money
whatever high amount you imagine that to
be would benefit his woman and his kids
so I don't even need to speak anymore I
have a question for the man out of this
list that we have um there's two things
that I'm surprised none of you said I'm
gonna curious if either of you put it on
really quick if you guess there's two
I'm surprised no one's sad wait no
previous kids beauty feminine virtuous
uh friend team player knows how to keep
a house submissive loyal Cooperative
ability to learn silence knows how to
mop dust vacuum virgin ideally cultural
food and in shape there's two things I'm
surprised no one but
I think somebody said it earlier I think
I might have heard one someone said no
previous kids oh no kidding no that's
part of Virgin isn't it yeah but you
can't find it there's no virgin I don't
know if well maybe you all are requiring
me I don't know I know you're definitely
requiring you're requiring
no one put sex
oh um
one in four marriages are sexless that's
true you guys think it's implied for
some reason women do not think it's
implied but we feel like it's implied
that you have to pay those bills every
month so I just think there's a
miscommunication and good with kids no
um
[Music]
okay so out of this list which one do
modern women struggle the most with
and then I'll put no sex
um okay what it's a different one
Cooperative Cooperative feminine so if
you were going to give a lesson on being
cooperative what would you say it's not
all about you that's that's where we
start it's not all about you like a
woman's world I think a lot of women
tend to Center themselves and make
everything about them when it's not
about them and I think it's hard to have
a conversation at that point to follow
on to that point as well they live in
their own reality their reality is their
reality we live in the real world like
we're real real world problems real
world interactions but they live in
their own reality that's why they only
see things through their lens they don't
see them through our lens as well nice
because women live in their feelings
whereas men are always based on logic so
that's that's what the end of the day so
what would you tell her
don't argue don't raise your voice to me
I I mean I've been with my wife like six
years and she's never raised a voice to
me even if someone's messaging some
somewhere and it can sound like they've
got bass in their voice I'm like you
need to take that bass out of your voice
my guy take the base out of your place
I think you have to I think you have to
let her know that I'm not your enemy
because women are very neurotic and they
are designed to see men as a threat so
yeah I'm not your enemy and then with
that with that comes when you know when
they start being defensive yeah that's
that's what comes that's what comes with
that as well and he's not your equal
that's the other thing
but I think a few times I mentioned
about um understanding and I think we're
in a day and age now we're not expecting
every girl to be a virgin
it may be unfortunate maybe but I think
just being like understandings that fact
I think they don't really
want the ability to like you're saying
understand we've been we've been told so
much all the time it's about as long as
the woman's happy happy wife happy life
like divorces only happen if the wife's
unhappy I think a big part of the
unhappiness is just feeling not heard or
not understood and there's there's only
so much that you can do because if I'm
just a crazy lady and I never feel heard
or understood like you know that's
different but if you're actually doing
some form of communication that I'm like
this man is not considering me at all
then yeah okay that's fair listen listen
I was chilling with a girl once that I
was seeing yeah
this girl started crying
we were sitting we were sitting in my
flat she started crying I said babe
what's wrong she said I don't know
that's a big that's a good answer I said
I said no like what's wrong what do you
mean what what happened
she said I don't know I said why are you
crying she said I don't know
are you are you upset yeah I'm upset
what are you upset about what happened I
don't know
tears dripping from my eyes
warm up
what's
what's the answer to that well I mean
okay so a lot of women
um like they can't even say I don't know
right so I that's actually pretty
self-aware for her to be like look I
don't have a reason right because I mean
you you guys have probably experienced
it like sometimes we get mad and has
nothing to do with you I've had
experiences like that where you know I
go to my husband I'm like I'm upset with
you I don't know why there's no reason
for it I'm in my feelings and he's like
all right I got it so I think that's
better than nothing how did you guys
respond to something like that um
I think a big I think your situation
where you're speaking about your husband
versus your situation it wasn't
that relationship that's why it hit you
difficult yo listen even if it was my
wife I'd still I'd be as baffled because
there's something going on here and I
don't know what to do you don't even
know there's no point as an assistant oh
you want to fix it yeah you can't fix it
you don't know the thing that's
bothering you so I just have to sit here
and watch you in tears and we don't we
don't know why the tears are happening
actually Yes actually yes you just like
yeah you sit there and watch me cry as
long as you can take it and if you got a
time limit you got a timeline my husband
will give me 30 minutes
I think as men yeah
I said to her not in a rude way I was
just like
you've been here for three days maybe
maybe
um you just need to you you need a break
so how is she there for three times
we've seen each other but that's that's
the point that's the point of saying
though if it's your wife for five years
example sadly she's in her feelings
where's she going
no but that's what I'm but that's what I
meant when I was that's what I meant
when I was saying about that the
difference right differentiation in
terms of like your wife
now yeah it's not ideal but we gotta
deal with this but when it's that
so Uber you know what I mean so it's
different it's a difference I don't
think he really wanted her like long
term like you say you're seeing each
other but it's like she's there for
three days she starts crying you're like
goodbye so I feel like you we weren't
really into it now if that was a woman
you wanted to wife up I feel like you
might have been a little bit more
patient no
if if something's happening around me
and there's no logical explanation I'm
gonna be just as confused
it doesn't matter whether it's a wife a
day it doesn't matter
the confusion like I don't know what to
do with that you know what as well yeah
I think some men don't understand women
in a sense of they just want to feel
things
so where she's just emotional and
there's just no
like explanation for it they just want
to feel it and US looking for a solution
is sort of getting them out of that
feminine thing because the feminine
energy is naturally chaotic and
confusing we're very logical as men and
women are very emotional so it does
conflict when you try and fix the
problem because there might not even be
a problem she might just be thinking
there's a problem when she can't
actually articulate what the problem is
or she can't actually imagine what the
problem is so she might actually just be
crying for things that she's feeling but
she doesn't actually know what the
problem is at all in those type of
situations I think it was Pro it will
probably be best just to leave her alone
just yeah do a thing Let Her Cry have a
moment after she's had her what half an
hour to cry then be like alright cool
let's go do something else you take her
mind off whatever it is and then boom
she's not upset no more to the ladies
yeah do you actually um based on what
we've just said do you actually want
solution oriented men
maybe to a degree because I mean I don't
I'm I am aware if I'm crying about
something and it's just my feelings and
I can say that and then if I want an
actual solution you know I have to
articulate that to my husband like
that's on me you know I need to tell you
I just want to feel heard right now or
okay I want to feel hurt also I need to
fix this problem and then he'll give you
Solutions but um it kind of gets in the
way uh because you don't necessarily
want your man to be your therapist your
therapist's supposed to you know solve
your your emotional feelings and things
like that but you just wanna you wanna
have somebody that cares that you're in
pain I think that's that's most of it
but I think women don't understand that
it is quite painful for a man to see the
woman that he cares about crying because
you can't you're helpless you can't do
anything about it
um but you know we there's some things
that we just can't help hormones are
really really strong and it's not an
excuse to have bad behavior but it is to
let you guys know like that's our
reality right and I've been finding out
a lot just being pregnant is absolutely
well your your wife is pregnant too
what's it been like my guy what's it
been like yeah she hasn't gone too too
crazy yet now she's starting to get a
little bit crazy yeah yeah I've got
something to add to the board as well
understand that men cannot read your
mind yes you have to articulate yourself
going to respect or cooperative uh I'd
stick it on both
it's his own thing you know okay okay
not mind readers I put it as a I'll put
it on the other side because these are
the action items a lot of the time the
women think that men should be able to
read their mind like if they're upset or
if they're hungry they expect their man
to know but it's like [ __ ] how do you
expect me to know how the [ __ ] do you
expect me to know that I can start
throwing things like you you hungry you
want some flowers have you guys ever
been on road trips with women yeah yeah
have you have you ever noticed that uh
and I don't know this might not be true
for everyone we'll ask if you have to go
to the bathroom because we have to go to
the bathroom
yeah yeah okay not so much and sorry
just to answer Paul's question because
she asked as a man like what'd you do in
that situation I think as a guy you'll
kind of role is supposed to be I got
this um analogy from Jay Waller shout
out to him but you're supposed to be
that um Cliff or that Boulder and her
waves of emotion just crash into that
and you just kind of subdue it if that
makes sense yeah yeah that made me feel
warm and fuzzy inside I feel like that's
correct yeah
okay what about oh man that broke
um what about sex how often do you guys
expect sex actually let's hear from the
the married guy how often do you expect
sex
y because because a lot of people have
these ideas in relationships and it's
different than marriage so I'm curious
from your point of view
to me and this is gonna sound a bit wild
but I just don't ever hurt don't ever
expect her to say no if I want to have
sex that is the deal that we've made is
as being married and you don't want me
to do of anyone else then that's what I
should do and that seems to work
literally on demand is what I'd say on
request I'm not sure with this one
because after I've seen a girl for a
while it tends to be her who's always
winning it and I'm a bit like oh I don't
want to be like there's a reason oh that
means that she's attracted to you that's
good there's a reason for that though
because scientifically men sex drive
declined as they age where it is women's
increases at the age yeah but it's not
it's not like my sex drive as a client
it's just like imagine you as a guy like
how many times a day do you really want
to like have sex it's not me it's it's
not only not only it's not just that
that that's a that is a fact but it's
not just that it's also once you've hit
it
and then you hit it again
it starts to you know what I'm saying
that's what I was gonna say about the
variety so do you think variety plays an
aspect of that as well um no because you
can still be into the girl but it's just
that that energy thing like because for
me sometimes I don't even want to like
not join sex because I want to retain
that energy so it's just like oh we have
to go again and I have to like use up
energy and potentially gonna if I have a
bus I haven't had sex
I think it actually just comes down to
the guy sometimes he just wants to bust
a nut he's just he's stressed he needs
to release that energy and he's gonna
and the wife is his release so at that
point it needs to be on demand because
the guy has a build up he wants to
release it well I mean you can't like I
can't turn on the water faucet on demand
you know what I mean then give head okay
I feel like I feel that Pearl you're
pushing towards how many times a day
versus how many days in a week do you
know what I mean no I'm just saying like
okay she's in a way you're an employee
right now there's this much that there's
like a minimum amount of work required
yeah what would you I what would you
expect
I would say there's no maximum and
there's no minimum it's what he said
just never say no never say no just
never say no if we're in a relationship
or we're married and if you want to have
it then I won't say no to you if if I
wouldn't have it then you don't say no
to me it's just it's fair that way well
I think Sex Drive is like very very by
men I know men have a higher sex drive
than women for sure just because of
testosterone levels we have like 117th
all the way to like 175th of like what
you guys have some of the time like some
men they want it you know three times a
day and then other men they want it a
couple times a week and I also think
that that honeymoon period you just want
to do it all the time on both sides
right so I think it depends on the guys
the question differently so we're in
wife's School we're saying that this is
what you should expect how often should
you expect to have sex in a relationship
at a minimum one to three times a week
that's a healthy marriage it sounds like
it three times a week minimum three
times a week be prepared for at least
once a day I'd say okay
when we're saying one to three times a
week we're talking individual actions
like
so that could be like once on a Monday
once on a Wednesday or once on a Friday
and that's a that's a good amount is
that what we're saying I'm asking um I
know you can say one to three times a
week is a is a standard marriage and if
no that's not that's I don't think
that's a standard marriage that's a
healthy marriage so I'm saying I'm
saying in your ideal world we have a
wife School we're saying to the Future
wives we're saying this is how much you
should expect to have sex with your
husband
free to fives is it a week
three to five days a week at least once
a day at least once a day at least once
a day once once a day maybe on some
occasions maybe maybe that their answer
is the correct answer but I would say I
don't think there's a number I believe
what these two gentlemen said earlier as
in on demand because on demand doesn't
necessarily mean once a day it could be
once a week it could be
um three times a week it could be once
every two weeks J as long as when the
guy wants it he gets it
um I think I think there's no number
it's just about that fulfillment yeah
when when sex becomes routine it does
get a bit dead so yeah on demand works
best for everyone even though on demand
sounds harsh but as I just described it
could mean it has to be said okay so so
let me ask you this because like well if
women are watching this we're just
getting intimidated right but um so like
I think this can run into a problem
where your wife is having sex with you
even if she doesn't want to and I think
that that's fair but I think
psychologically it can kind of you know
just like kill the mood completely so
what what is your stance on that because
there are times where you're not going
to be in the mood as a woman or maybe
you're stressed out or you know like
like kids and things like that so like
what level of understanding you know can
a woman expect from a man I guess that
goes both ways yeah yeah I mean don't
starve him you know what I mean like you
guys you can't because then you can't
get mad if he cheats right yeah well I
think look there's different
expectations how you guys feel about us
putting our way paying bills supporting
in-house Soul or whatever it may be all
these things things we expect the same
level of stuff when we're talking about
physical intimacy so when you talk about
old all of these things are happening
with kids and family that's fine but
does that mean that if all those things
are happening for me as well I don't get
sex because of that like I still there's
still things I have to commit to well
it's like do you want you you can you
can manufacture genuine desire right so
like my point is this like if you
married probably like to your first
choice because this is probably how that
would work it's like you can't wait to
jump as bones you know what I mean like
you have that and but I think there are
seasons of life where you do have stress
and then so is that really what you
would want is just like sex even when
she doesn't want it now however I do
think some women fully expect that but
once you get started you do end up
getting in the mood so you know it could
be like a five to ten minute situation
where she's like okay actually I wanted
to have sex the whole time I just didn't
know so I guess like that's what I'm
trying to pick your guys's brains about
do you want a woman to have sex with you
even if she doesn't want to yes it
should be a duty because at the end of
the day you can't say to a man isn't
allowed to say oh I don't want to pay
the rent this week or I I don't wanna I
don't want to go to I don't want to
protect you exactly oh there's a there's
a burglar you can kill her at first it's
fine like your man's not allowed to the
same way I believe a woman's not
actually allowed to if she wants to have
a healthy marriage or relationship it
needs to be like that you say that but
then if you are going to have sex and
she doesn't want to do it then it's just
not going to be the same like me I like
to have a intense session where we're
both enjoying it yeah
and the girl doesn't want to have sex
she's not really going to put in the
effort and there's not going to be that
little oomph and it's not just going to
be enjoyable it's just like once you
bust your nut that's it I'm curious just
show a hand who would want their girl to
have sex with them even if they don't
want to show her hands oh damn
okay don't be scared to oh it's
interesting I'm surprised the
overwhelming majority here that you
don't want your girl to have sex with
you if she doesn't want to because you
can feel it look I know women who been
married like 33 years or 18 years but I
I associate with a specific group of
wives okay these women like having sex
with their husband and have like love
doing it for decades but like you you
have to have that genuine desire but
that's the problem is I think like women
are ending up in relationships with men
that they're consenting to they're not
attracted to this guy but he'll do and I
think that's how you end up in a sexless
marriage I think you shouldn't get
married unless you're both attracted to
each other otherwise it just won't work
problems come from unattraction if
there's no attraction guys shouldn't get
married no I think they should get
married to they should get married to
ugly girls so I think one should be
married to ones two should be married to
twos right right that's how it should be
and now you say that yeah but a lot of
ugly guys sometimes tend to have money
and they're getting with these really
pretty girls and then this is a catch-22
and what you're saying then that bumps
them up and then the girl has to pay for
that so if the guys are three and he's
making a million that might put him up
to like a six sometimes ugly dudes have
a game though you know what I mean like
the majority of the town they do yeah
I'm sure they have to yeah
looking guys don't have nothing it's
just a body and that's it and if she's
going for money I think she has to
accept the fact that she's chosen money
so she has to also accept that she's
chosen it to be in a situation where
she's going to have to have sex even if
she doesn't want to true I feel like
that's if you've chosen money then
that's your fault and you have to accept
accountability for that action but if
you want to be in a successful marriage
where it's happy and you're both
attracted to each other go for someone
you're actually attracted to that's how
it should be I think when women put too
much emphasis on a man's looks they
enter it into their masculine it's meant
to be the man that's meant to desire the
woman for her beauty and I think what's
going on now is women are expecting too
much in terms of men's Beauty and
women's standards for beauty have just
dropped social media has changed women's
mindsets yeah but y'all be gassing up
these whales
come on you know come on
some of these fat chicks have this type
of confidence you know it happens to
guys like that like come on my show and
they'll be like oh she was cute and I
was like she's like 50 pounds overweight
what do you mean you know I think it has
a lot to do with it as well and this you
might not agree with me on this but I
feel like lockdown had a lot to do with
men and how we move in this day and age
because a lot of men during lockdown
wasn't able to do what they was doing
before I feel like women took more
control after that in the sense of now I
feel like it's harder for guys to get
girls because of I feel that social
media boosted at that point whereas
before it was there but it wasn't so
important whereas now you have to be a
certain level of caliber in order to get
recognized I think what it is is you
still have eighty percent of the girls
going for the top ten percent of guys
it's always been like that but it's been
more visible now thanks to stuff like
social media right so that's why and
that's what I said earlier about the
reality thing because they live in their
own reality to them every guy is six
foot three every guy earns this amount
of money every guy looks like this etc
etc and that thoughts down to other
things because then they also think
those kind of guys usually have a lot of
options therefore they might mess about
a little bit they might cheat whatever
so now they think all guys cheat well
not really you're ignoring 80 of the
guys because you're only dealing with
the top 20. so they have a very skewed
view of what guys are there's guys like
we said earlier ugly guys
ugly guys won't matter
like if they're if they substance like
supplement it with other things money
look status etc etc etc right so if but
there's a big big proportion of guys who
aren't doing that and those kind of guys
and completely invisible to girls but do
you know do you know what that's what
I'm saying here I think a man's value is
not determined by how attractive he is I
agree yeah so when when a woman puts all
the emphasis on a man's Beauty um
that's a masculine woman yeah I think
and I think a lot of the things where
you said about the person being like 50
pounds overweight I think a lot of the
time females forget about intention so
that just because the the man might say
yeah cute
he might just be trying to do that oh
yeah yeah I don't want a relationship
with you but we can be better
but I did like a rating with this guy
and he he ran it like a girl overweight
a below above average but the thing is
though in in
his real mind he's thinking of four but
he's looking but but he wants to do that
and then what happens when we're having
all of these conversations we're
distorted the females break left right
and said next thing you know it's just a
one big blurred line and I think that
when you mention obviously going for
different looks and because I think you
said something about three for free four
for four five or five because that girl
that makes maybe a four
got the man for an that was a man but
didn't show any intention no but it's
all Matt you see you see when guys are
rating girls seven eight and nines
that's just in their world in the real
world that rating drops by like three
years you guys are in London so it's
like a little bit they're not that cute
here um
a guy will actually over inflate the
rating for a girl depending on his
current
um mindset so if he's been starving for
a while so he's horny a guy who's horny
is obviously going to actually think of
the guy as more attractive like I've
I've I'm sure a lot of guys have
experienced it before you're very in the
mood you haven't had it for like a
couple of days or a week or something
and then you start seeing girls who you
wouldn't normally go for as a bit more
attractive and appealing and then after
you bust your knot and you've got post
not Clarity like oh what am I doing
there not feeling already exactly that
is true I have a question about about
cheating
who here would like to be able to cheat
in a relationship raise your hand
like to yeah
how many of you would like to be able I
didn't say expect to be able to would
like to be able to cheat in a
relationship like to explain situation
if she loves you she's with you but you
can cheat when you want I'd like to we
had this discussion okay exercising
options whatever you would like to have
sex with other girls
yeah no why why not so my younger self
would have said yes but it's like if
you're gonna do that then like I feel
that
hmm how can I how can I word this in a
way that the comments won't kill me
too late nah what I mean is yeah like in
my younger days cheating was easy that
I'll do it and feel no type of way but
now in my older age it's like
I wouldn't necessarily say that's the
right thing and if if you've got
permission to do it then it's different
but if there's no permission and you're
gonna go out and do it then yeah like
it's for me personally gone sorry I
gotta finish no I was gonna say then I
wouldn't want to do it because I'm not
trying to let my woman down like I want
to build up our relationship and I want
us both to be strong enough and we're in
a happy position where we both love and
trust each other would it be a benefit
to you guys if a girl let you cheat like
if she said you know what what you do I
if I don't know about it I don't care
would that be a benefit to you guys of
course I think most men would love that
yeah definitely that's that's not
standard so so how many of you guys that
raised your hand right if your girl put
out whenever you wanted it would you
keep your hand raised I wouldn't look
what do you mean I wouldn't go out of my
way
okay okay because some guys some guys
like they
they variety no matter what so I'm just
like I'm saying it's ever said no
I want the right to cheat you know what
I mean
I mean I was still I was still want the
right to cheat but
monogamy is not normal though monogamy's
old has been forced upon men most men if
they had their way and they knew there
would be no pushback from women they
would want to have multiple women yeah I
think it's also because women that
aren't Sometimes women look
at sex with their lenses as opposed to
ours our lens is very much like it's
it's a sex is a physical actor it's a
physical act right but most women need
to have some sort of emotional
connection even if they don't the first
time the second time and the third time
an emotional connection will build right
so we think about it differently so
therefore it should be treated
differently but they wanted to us to
treat it the same as them but we're not
the same as them so how can we treat it
the same time I'll just take a tired
Playboy like I'm good I'll take a I'll
take a retired player I'm good you get
your fill so a question how many of you
think you could be faithful to a girl
long term like you have it in you
yeah doing it right now okay so everyone
feels like they could but most of you
would want to cheat if you could and it
would be a benefit if a girl let you do
that it'd make her more wifey I mean if
a girl was to say yo like I want to be
in a relationship with you and I don't
mind if you cheat I don't think any man
is going to be upset about that no man
is probably about for me but it could be
a test at the same time for me if she
meant it you think it was a you'd think
it was a trap yeah yeah okay yeah for me
the only reason I would half put my hand
up for that is because if she was to say
to me do you know what you can
number one it would make me not even
want to do it anyway but and then number
two the only thing and maybe it's an ego
thing that would exercise is this girl
rapes me you know but still I wouldn't
even want to do it but you really have
got love for me because you would really
let me do it nah you're the one but
still
I wouldn't do it and we all know certain
type of men don't cheat so we yes yeah
we wouldn't want to do that I can't like
you know what happens as well actually
in that scenario it will actually make
her more attractive to you so the reason
why I say that is because when you're
dating and you're dating multiple women
and women know that other women want you
they get more excited by that so when it
comes to a situation like that she knows
that he could go and get other guys but
then that being said if you're being
faithful to her and not exercising
options to her she's like I'm the one
who's won but I still the thing is is
competition anxiety in it you need they
need to understand that
they should never think that you can't
get anyone else but them let's let's be
wrong because no woman wants a guy who
no other woman wants it's just not how
it works yeah that's true do I mean like
I'm a faithful man I'll just put that
out there right now I'm a faithful man
but us get attention every now and then
from girls and it was my wife up but she
knows in it like obviously I'm not going
to do anything because I'm a mad man you
know I'm a man of God and that but
it you know it gets them saying okay I
need to be on point I need to be on game
because people are looking at my man
so I mean and that fact is in a to a lot
of positive through your relationship
she's not going to balloon to the size
of a well if she knows that okay this
guy can walk out and he won't even have
to do anything and he can get someone
else she understands what she has so she
stays on her toes yeah that actually
happened to me so I go back and forth
between like whether or not I'm sexually
jealous but um so my husband's older but
he would tell me I could pull chicks but
I'd never seen it because I'm not a type
of person like I don't really believe
people like that so I was like this fan
said he could I was like I've never seen
it in real life and then one day we went
down to a creek I live in the Midwest
and I just went off to like explore and
I was a little bit pudgy at the time you
know and so I came back three to five
minutes later and there's like this
bubbly 19 year old in a bikini like you
know giggling flipping her hair at him I
was like oh my God and but I never I had
never been put in that position I was
like oh I guess I guess I am kind of a
jealous girl in that way and so I mean
it did inspire me to like you know hit
the gym and take it like cereals like oh
oh like I gotta I gotta keep on toes but
that was my fault because I don't really
feel that way when I know that I'm on
point when I know that I look good it's
like when I'm slipping up where I'm like
oh I'm getting concerned but um to the
cheating thing I think women just have
to be reasonable a lot of infidelity
occurs in marriages I think you just
can't expect your man to stay faithful
if you're not if you're not put in any
anything out there for him you know and
so it's also like I think women lie too
like they think that if they've been
married 18 years they have three kids
that if he cheats that they're okay I'm
Gonna Leave the marriage that might not
be the smartest thing to do that might
be something that you need to go to
couples counseling over or you need to
burn it down according to Modern women
who cares they'll just be screw the kids
no just burn it burn it down 20 years
one night yeah over question though yeah
question what is cheating
and the reason why I asked that yeah is
because
if a man has no if a man doesn't sleep
with another man's wife and he's just
sleeping with another woman just to get
a nut off is that cheating
why does that have to go in yeah I feel
like it has to go it matters because it
matters because if you're gonna def if
you're gonna Define cheating I think we
want men to have options right
so if a man just uses a woman just this
is gonna sound bad but for ejaculation
purposes only and he doesn't sleep with
another man's wife
and he comes back to his his main wife
and he does all the things he's supposed
to do as a husband as a father or
whatever
what's the crime I mean there's two
things one obviously a lot of men say oh
she was better than my hand I've heard
that a lot I've heard that on this
Stream So that so men's that's a
different case but I don't see the the I
don't understand the point of why does
it have to not be someone else's wife
why does someone else's relationship
impact mine because at the end of the
day if you are sleeping with someone
just for sex and the other person wants
to if she's gonna cheat she's gonna
cheat so it doesn't really matter if
it's another man's wife or not in that
case well historically it has mattered
actually so I mean there's lots of
cultures that have had you know rules
laws legislation about infidelity and
what that looks like and then in the
past like men men have had the
opportunity to to cheat from like a
Christian context if it wasn't another
man's wife so I understand what you're
saying but it's like it's 2022 I don't
think people are really putting
standards on any type of cheating it's
just like you know whatever whatever
goes down goes down but I I know what
you mean it probably would be worse if
you were you know being in some other
guy's wife well I don't think you'd want
to risk your life like that so do you
think women are mentioning the same
thing no no but there I think there's
reasons that women cheat that men don't
want to hear about
um like you know we're looking for
something we're looking for that
intimacy or that closeness and we might
feel ignored it's just that women have
to understand you know context of the
situation if you're you know a
stay-at-home wife your man's working 60
hours a week yeah you're gonna feel
lonely oh no it doesn't mean that you go
sleep with the neighbor it means that
you try to you try to hit him up when he
comes home from work but not too soon
you got to be quiet first yeah yeah 30
minutes 30 minutes maybe give them 45.
so females are doing it genuinely for a
void uh it depends because you know we
got these city girls so there are
something else I'm just speaking from
like there are times where good women do
end up feeling like compelled to cheat I
know that that sounds weird to you guys
but if it's just like problem after
problem after problem I feel like my
husband doesn't notice me yeah you might
start looking elsewhere for it but I
think women women cheat emotionally but
it's interesting too
um so like I think there's different
standards too because I don't know that
I'd care that much if my husband slept
with another woman I realized oh no like
the internet's gonna be like but you're
a Christian look there's there's like
reasons for this but um I think I would
be offended if this man was accepting
another woman's phone calls and she was
like crying on the phone venting her
emotions to him I'd be like oh no or if
he was like taking her out on dates and
spending a bunch of money I'd be like
this is not right this is unjust how
could you do this to me shooting
emotions like a completely different
thing if I've got one wife and I'm
already doing that for her there is no
way I'm doing that for another one I
mean the entire point is the entire
point of actually doing those things and
actually dealing with a woman's emotions
is because you actually want that woman
in the form of a relationship you want
her to be yours because she's a threat
because you like her personality exactly
and that's that's where that's where it
gets a bit weird because men normally
only cheat physically because they need
a variety it's like food if you eat
lasagna every day for the rest of your
life you might get bored of it so if it
but if you alternate between like
lasagna Pizza like lobster yeah I just
choose not to be in a relationship with
women that are that are hungry
I have a question is there such thing as
a woman doing too much
yeah I've just heard the phrase she does
too much or don't do too much well in
terms of that oh she's just forcing it
without doing the most yeah yeah yeah
doing the most I've heard that too so
much so guys so guys point of view what
does that mean I didn't stress or can I
have an example annoying me
no I think I think she means like female
simping
yeah I know but that's that's only
because
to the moon and back we won't complain
if we want you if we don't want you stop
it I don't feel like you hear about it
so much in relationships like personally
anyway I don't think I've heard from
males like oh she's doing the most
you're doing too much in a relationship
it's pre that who gets like talking face
so what's what's too much in the talking
situation chip courting whatever
whatever you want to call it in 2022
face
it forcing everything too quickly
especially if you don't really like or
you're just trying to figure things out
it's like when you're dating someone in
the beginning you always say I don't
know what I'm looking for I'm not
looking for anything because if it
doesn't amount to anything it didn't
amount to anything but amounts if if you
say oh yeah I'm looking for something
I'm looking for something and it doesn't
matter anything somehow you're a
[ __ ] now so you know uh so that's
kind of just guys not wanting to be the
bad guy and it's not even open yeah yeah
because then she can't come to you later
until you promise something that you
didn't I think like at the at the
talking stage
um a girl
coming up with like so what are we or
where's this going like a couple months
in I think that's doing too much
wait no
okay okay depends how many months in so
how many months
like um for me I've always said like
four seasons on the road trip
Four Seasons and a road trip yeah that's
how that's how long you kind of need to
that's not that's how long you that's
how long you need to kind of know
someone you know so you talk to a girl
you you do like the situationship thing
for a year if it's going to be a
situationship
um then yeah for a year before you kind
of decide whether you want to lock it
down or not okay roughly what do you
guys think is that uh if if you live
together if if like you if you spend a
lot of time together in each other's
yards and each other's places
um to the point where you borderline
living together than less than a year
maybe six months maybe six months so if
she asks you that it's six months is it
doing too much yeah if if we were
spending a lot of time together within
in that six months like sleepovers yeah
sorry you mean you mean having sex
though not just no but sleepovers
literally sleeping like waking up with
each other like you know what I'm saying
seeing seeing each other's lives and
that if it's like that then six months
is okay but if it's not like that and
it's a situationship where you you don't
spend too much time together like that
then yeah you need you need you need at
least a year like for me I don't really
like the phrase like doing too much and
doing them because as as males I feel
sometimes you have to have a level of
like accountability so we'll say oh we
don't want a girl to have x amount of
bodies whatever it be six seven bodies
so in one hand we're saying this
and then in one hand we're saying when
she wants to take it to the next level r
she's doing too much when she's asking
the question but we full well know if
that she's had x amount of wears
previous to us
we're gonna be feeling away I feel like
it it's kind of counterproductive in a
way to say that a female wanting to know
the position that she's in
I feel like it's kind of their rat
because there's so much emphasis on her
body's Rising I think I know what you're
saying it's like you it's like when men
say that they want traditional women but
a traditional woman is not going to be
in a situation except in a situationship
and having premarital sex like if she
actually is traditional so it's like you
you can't you can't really have both
right but I I also think my man's in the
back I think he's just in a city boy
phase you know he'll come around wait no
actually my my question for you because
to me like again as a woman we know we
only have so much time so to me I'm like
if a guy is waiting a year that's a long
time here's the thing if you especially
if you want to get married okay I've
been working hard for a long time
I've built quite a bit
for me to put that on the line for
someone to come in and be in a position
where they could affect that in any way
I have to know that person
for me to let that person in to that
level I have to know that person if I'm
dating that person for a year I believe
with my
decent sense of judgment which I believe
I have
after that year I believe I would have
seen enough to say yes or no
if I spend a lot more time with that
person we stay each other stay at each
other's places of residence for let's
say days at a time a week and then and
then a couple days break and so on then
it can be less it can be six months
before I can feel like I re when I feel
like I know you
it's not just that you look good because
that's going to go one day but when I
feel like I know you
and I can trust you
and you've got to remember what we were
oh sorry so I'm just curious I just want
to get a raise of hands how long do you
want to talk like situationship Court
however you want to call it a girl
before you make it official so I'm going
to say three months
you're good with three months you're
good with three months okay six months
so six months six months
okay six roughly six okay eight months
eight months and then a year okay so so
I it seems like the most common one it's
like six months I think that was the
most hands I feel like six months is
first because that's when you can that's
I feel like that's an ample amount of
time for you to truly get to know
someone if it was three months it's like
three months goes by that that and and
like a lot can happen in in three months
but then a lot more can happen in six
months and if you're spending a lot of
time with each other like he said if
you're staying at X's house and she's
staying at your house and like I feel
like you guys can truly get to know one
another but if it's in a time frame of
three months then you're not gonna know
that person she's not gonna really know
you and it's like I don't feel like the
relationship is it could be long-lasted
because
again you don't know each other I think
it comes down to what you actually mean
by make it official because that some to
to people that's different so for
someone make it official might mean oh
just a relationship or just mutually
sleeping with each other so I mean I'm
exclusively so when I said that I met
like boyfriend girlfriend oh after three
months become yeah yeah yeah yeah three
months is enough for that I think yeah
yeah I feel like it's a relationship the
reason I feel like three months because
on average if you look at it like one
one day during a week
one weekend day
over three months that's that's plenty
of time well because I it's like I
understand where the men and the women
are coming from because the woman's
point of view you only have so much time
and so every year of your 20s like that
that's less fertility that you have
every year but from the guy's point of
view you guys are risking more today
than ever before getting married and
committing to women and you get less out
of it so of course you're going to vet
them more yeah but haven't you noticed
that the cultures that talk about having
more and more relationship experience
have the worst marital practices and the
worst of worse rates yes whereas like
there's other cultures where it's like
no there is no relationship experience
you me you're gonna get engaged very
quickly and you'll be married within
three to six months and those those
cultures those marriages do fine so um I
I did want to ask you guys a question by
a show of hands though have you ever met
a woman that you wanted to marry
straight away well just just enjoy ever
ever I've met a woman I've wanted
tomorrow straight away yeah actually
raise up hands
um how long did it take you to know you
wanted to marry her
a week so I'm gonna okay okay I'm gonna
say say within three months
did you know you wanted to marry her
three months
So within okay so so in a way if you
really like the girl you don't need that
much time yeah but I did on that like my
thing was I thought I wanted to and that
true colors came out after like six
months so there was a facade there so
you I didn't the person I thought I was
when it's Amari wasn't actually that
person so that's why which is why which
is why we need double that time yeah I
don't I don't knock the time thing
because with time you can make a more
informed decision and I think what it
goes to show as in if you make a
decision which is more informative time
it benefits the man because time works
in men's favor as opposed to women's
favor and also to add on to that as well
a lot of women have a crazy side and I
feel like in six months she can't hide
her crazy side she's gonna show you her
true colors so that's why I feel like
six months is the perfect amount of time
if it's three months she can hide that
she can act like this girl that you want
because it's all an act but if it's six
months now there's only so long that you
can continue it on four before she ends
up challenge you don't think a woman can
had a crazy side for six months she
could do but if you spend a lot of time
with her then it's harder for her to do
that um I I don't think that there's any
way to go about this risk-free like some
of you guys are just gonna get unlucky
and end up in relationships with psychos
it's the same thing with women they're
like oh every man is a narcissist like
you you just might be unlucky I don't
think there's a hundred percent secure
way to go about any of this yeah I don't
think it's gambling sorry sorry gambling
gambling is is not a good thing but if I
was gonna bet on a football match I'd
bet on man united to beat Barnett
I think it actually also comes down to
the kind of dynamic in the relationship
so even if she is crazy if you have an
iron fist it's not going to be that much
of a problem if there is that Dynamic of
utter respect it doesn't matter how
crazy she is she knows she can't come up
to you and start shouting at you or
doing crazy [ __ ] because of the way
you're going to respond so as long as
there is that high level of respect
understanding the man's not going to
take it you have to just demean yourself
and understand that the man is the man
and you are the woman at the end of the
day so and a man's not going to take it
so if you are in that position doesn't
matter how crazy you are you need to
control yourself otherwise [ __ ] is gonna
happen well then she doesn't get the
benefits as well of being in a
relationship as well if she's constantly
constantly a certain type of way that is
exactly why she doesn't get the benefit
it's like we mentioned the
situationships there's a reason that
you're not wife there's a reason you're
not long-term girlfriend and that is
established by your behavior men don't
talk a lot but we understand that we
watch we watch a lot of your actions and
what you do and that's what we base you
on you might say all of this but we're
watching what you're doing and that will
be did the side in fact are if we're
going to take you seriously or not so
question for them for other guys how
long if you had a sister a friend how
long is too long to wait in a
situationship where it's just he doesn't
like you she's never being in a
situationship
okay fine everyone else
to my younger siblings or anything I'll
say at least if you're seeing a guy for
at least a minimum of nine months and he
hasn't made no like no indication that
he wants to make you his girl then yeah
you're just gonna have to keep it moving
otherwise he's going to be played the
fool because he's just running game on
you for me I'd have to I'd have to run
with three months I'd still have to run
with it again and I forgot did you say
it takes you three months or it takes
you longer than that yeah three months
oh you said three months okay let's say
six six
I go for eight eight
six six
if I if I had the door off yeah because
it's just interesting because I see the
guy's point of view but I also see the
women's point of view if I had a
daughter or I was speaking to my my
sister or my nieces
in a group I would say to them
um if a guy hasn't committed to you
after a year
um then leave that guy and how long
would you want after the year of the or
three months to a year of a
situationship how long would it take you
guys to marry the girl
ideally would you guys want I think in
this day and age it's hard to even
answer that question because oh wait
actually I'm sorry sorry I have to cut
you off how many want to be married
raise your hand
yeah okay okay so you you are married
yeah okay
so for the guys that actually want to be
married how long would it take you it
depends so if I know that I want to
marry her yeah I could do it immediately
immediately yeah I don't even need any
type if I know everything about her I
know I don't like there's no guesswork I
don't need to I don't need to figure
stuff out if I know everything I need to
know about her I can just get married so
the the three to I think three to six
months was that what you said no I said
three months three months period of of
getting to know her you make her your
girlfriend you can marry her the next
year yeah okay okay ah cool so for me
I'd have to be seeing the girl for at
least five years before I propose and
then after five years I think then I
would propose and then I'd want at least
another two years whilst we're engaged
before we actually get married so we're
looking at seven years
I'm gonna have to agree with that one as
well I'm gonna do it seven years you
know traditional women don't do that
like it's not gonna happen you will end
up with a city girl because she's the
type that's gonna wait Ali I disagree
with you I know I know a lot of girls
that and that in a way honestly they've
made the right guy they have that
genuine desire for and get [ __ ] by it
there's a girl I know that's a virgin
and she's been she's like they're in her
mid-30s with the same dude and she still
she doesn't have a ring no kids and
she's running out of time for the right
guy yeah yeah okay oh like yeah I guess
I guess that's true but I don't know I I
live in a specific area I know a lot of
like Christian wives and husbands and
stuff so my perspective is like a little
bit different so yeah but I wouldn't
recommend it to my daughter I'd be like
come on girl no I agree I mean seven
years how how much do you guys think
weddings cost so the type of wedding I'm
trying to have isn't no wedding that's
just gonna be like that out the way
actually why are we spending 10K in a
wedding I just don't get it like we can
we can get it we can go to the
courthouse tomorrow and that's the and
that's the energy that's that's sort of
refreshing but I hate your type of
scales but for me from so I said three
months relationship
including the three months though I'd
say two years engagement
and then another three years on top for
that for that for the wedding for me two
and then five so we're together five
years seven years no I said five years
before I propose seven years before I
get married
and then an extra three for a wedding so
five years old together okay five years
seven sorry Paul can I just ask them a
question so why the two years engagement
why so it's a plan so two so two years
to enjoy the relationship to do the
process to see if this is the person you
wanna
have children with because for me if I'm
not going to have children with the
person
then it is there's no point in in
marriage I'm not looking to get married
to have no children but you've given it
a ring doll
yeah but no that's why I said I said two
years to then get to that stage okay
awesome I said sorry from obviously I
said Fremont gets a relationship but
from the zero to after two years if I
know this person get engagement so not
to not to jump in the queue so so here's
here's where my one year of getting to
know each other comes in I would I would
do all pretty much most of that within
that one year I would have like for me
to be someone's boyfriend you've got oh
I'm not gonna get married I don't I
don't I don't really believe in marriage
yeah it's it's not impossible for me to
get married but it's not really would
you do it would you do a ceremony and
not the government potentially
potentially But but so in that one year
of getting to know that person and
getting to know each other it covers
most of this so that's so that's the
thing like I wouldn't even be your
boyfriend if I couldn't see you as a
mother or a wife okay I like you now so
that so so that's the that's the thing
and and for me I like we all have a
different style and the thing is
everything's about like um that
thresholds right so it's just it's just
like cool so now after three months I
want to make you my my girlfriend now
after the after the girl from stage
we're working towards that now it's you
know I mean it's just like it's
different threshold it's not like I'm
putting them through tests I think just
I feel like it just makes why would you
make her your girlfriend if you have no
intentions of making her your wife I I
would never do that
that's what that's what I'm saying I
wouldn't it's just about it's just about
time and I'm not gonna make my
girlfriend next day engaged my next day
that that's what I'm saying about the
time skills so you think you could
identify a wife and you want to have
kids yeah yeah and a mother within three
months
what are you saying like that it's it's
wild like when you say like that but if
that's not what I'm saying is though if
we're saying that that even six months
as well but what I'm saying is to be in
a relationship with somebody after three
months if you're seeing each other two
times two times a week I personally
don't think that's wild same question
then in a different way so you would be
in a would you be in a relationship with
someone without knowing without feeling
like you can see them as the mother of
your children or your wife
would you be in a relationship with that
person
I don't think I would so you you've so
then what you're saying is you need a
longer period of time like me
that's the point of dating is to see if
you think that that it would be like
viable if you guys are compatible like I
actually what I think like most people
do that are into marriage I think
they'll date for a year I think they'll
get engaged for a year and then after
that year is up I think they'll get
married but that's the point I got
nothing wrong I mean I don't find
anything wrong uh with a long engagement
I think that that makes perfect sense I
think that's fair but a woman wants to
know that she's like off the market I
want to show something off and say hey
it's about communicating realistic time
frames I think that's what it's about if
you just say to her look at the minute
I'm not in a position to get engaged I
don't want to get engaged yet however
within a year year and a half that's and
sticking to it that's the most important
thing then this is why sometimes women
get um obviously annoyed because
they think your word is bond and it
should be so if you're saying to someone
look like when I met my wife I remember
we was at a wedding and one of her
friends tried to bring me on smoke and
say oh you guys not going to get engaged
yet or whatever but we already had that
conversation and said this is when we're
going to engage this is the sort of time
frame we're looking to get engaged when
we're looking to get mad etc etc but you
need to just be apparent to them and
stick by it so don't lead them on with
oh yeah maybe one day one day but then
again I know to flip for that I know
guys who have literally told their
current girlfriend that they're with
yeah I don't want to marry you so how
long and she still stayed with him and
she still stayed with us
guys I want to get through the actual
question so seven years seven years you
don't believe in marriage how long for
you
I would say a year a year and you could
get married yeah a year oh wow okay just
to change mine I'd say if they're like
you said if there was no ceremony okay
so you would you would do ceremonies
okay it's a ceremony okay how long would
it take you to get to a ceremony three
years three years
how long did it take me uh it should
have been two years but it was three
three because it covered okay wow the
seven that's no I said five no no I want
to know when I get like like as the girl
you get down the aisle and start oh my
God that would be
I I understand more than anyone like
where the guys are coming from but seven
years is a lot well you guys you guys
know we get smoke for that right like
people start looking at us funny like
you know it's like to be honest I'm not
even sure how many women would even get
married were it not for the female
social pressure
and that's not the woman that you want
to marry the one who's doing it for that
reason exactly I know but it's there
it's they look you can't get rid of it
if you're not married by 30 people look
at you funny no matter what so like that
that reality exists so like I understand
why you guys want to wait yeah I'm just
also making you guys aware of the fact
that like we do get looked at funny the
longer that we we hold on to because
people are like you don't expect
anything out of this but you know why
um I actually I don't know why I just
know that girls do it there's a funny
joke in my community as well where the
girl is getting married to have the big
wedding and then she the joke is oh but
now she has to sleep with the husband as
well like oh suddenly the guy I'm
marrying wants to do more than cuddle
right yeah I understand but I got I got
married like super low budget um just
because we had we were trying to get it
done but I had like my reception
of your partner before you got married
before I got married I think we this is
hard uh I think we were together for a
year and a half I think so that was when
we got married
mm-hmm
let's be I think I think people know
whether their partner is marriage
material quite early I'll say around
around six months to a year I think
people have made up their mind like you
know what
I can I'll take a bet on this one or
I'll pass on this one I'm sorry so I
personally think if we're gonna take
that into account
the age of the woman how many kids you
want
I don't see the point of waiting seven
years if we meet a woman at 25 what
you're gonna wait five years so you're
gonna wait five years to find out if
she's the one seven years to propose but
she's 32 at that time
I'd actually also add most men have a
like a checklist in their head of what
they want their wife to like they have
certain things about their wife and they
want to make sure she has it doesn't
take that long to figure it out yeah
there's certain things you want you can
figure them out within three to six
months you can figure them out like if
you have literal checklists in your mind
does she do this can she do that you can
figure them out quickly you can
literally ask her you can ask questions
you can figure them out after time
things do show it doesn't take that long
to figure out your checklist and if you
if everything is checked on your
checklist I have no problem immediately
marrying because then I know I found the
one what do you guys think what do you
what do you guys think so the guys that
had so you too and who is the next
longest after seven years
oh five seven five did you say three
last of the year yeah are you two said
three yeah okay what do you guys think
of the phrase area before you carry do
you think that's for you too especially
do you think that's true yes you should
marry before you carry 100.
I mean I have a kid now so I don't feel
like I could answer that question
you can still answer it if you could go
back to me me obviously in in the same
position I have a I have a five-year-old
daughter
however I fully believe in that though I
fully believe that's like that's like
the right way right I think that if I'm
gonna say oh just because I didn't do it
I'll be I'll be I'll be lying you know
what I mean so there's a level
accountability we've got to have with
that situation and and for me that would
110 be be the ideal and it's like what I
said before
I wouldn't marry without the intention
to have a child yeah so when I do the
only way that I will be having my next
child
would be following marriage and and
that's a hundred and ten percent
um a bit so how old are you now 128 now
28 so you meet a girl tomorrow let's say
you're the same age you wouldn't have a
kid with her until she's 32.
it's wild yeah no it's just interesting
because I really understand where the
guys are coming from but it's like the
one thing that we kind of have
conflicting is like marriage is a bad
contract but we want people to be
married to have kids so how do you
reconcile that
I think it's a
so we have we I think we all have our
guidelines but there's a level of like
communication that you've gotta that
you've got to have around I think that's
like that's like the key thing to it
because obviously the female body's
changing the eggs are exit what is it
after is it after 30 they start dropping
I think 90 of your eggs are gone by age
30.
why I think some
some choosing wrong even though that's
hard I know women are crazy but I think
that it's just so hard for you guys to
get women they're like the first nice
girl that comes along and it's like yeah
have sex with you for the rest of my
life you're like okay I will wipe her up
and I think that's how a lot of guys get
stuck because they're not looking at
like character because if you think
about like with the standard that most
men have for relationships it's like you
know is she nice is she pretty does she
stick around like yeah I could see how
you know she ends up like taking you for
half because you know she she could be
off right that's why you need to have
these long periods where you need to
understand like like my mom's saying
about a year and all stuff it's that's
the whole point of that to make sure
that doesn't happen and the longest the
longer time you do it
um the more sort of tests you put
through then it will limit minimal your
risk of being in a situation and also
it's the fact that some guys just don't
have a lot of options and they don't
think they can get better so they focus
on this one person of who who like you
say do you know what as well yeah I
think this is gonna as men
a year wasted is not that bad yeah and
this is not this is not even to sound
crazy but okay say a man's 29 yeah and
he meets a woman at 29 they get into a
relationship the relationship doesn't
work
the way the woman is looking at the
world at 30 and the same the way the man
is looking at the world at 30 is not the
same yeah so you could always bounce
back and I think with men are kind of
scared to get it wrong
it makes sense because it's such a bad
contract for men so it just sounds like
most men are willing to take the risk
even though there's nothing in it for
them really nowadays
if the girl puts in the time
and almost like as much as as like the
woman in me is like wow that's so much
time I understand it it almost seems
like it makes the deal more fair even
though it's unfair for men it goes back
to our argument that we feel we think
logically we think how can we minimize
the risk yeah because it's a safe bet is
this okay whatever the worst can happen
how much is this gonna damage me and a
man at 30 35 years old as we go up our
money gets more you know we get more
handsome our beards grow more you know
stuff like that so there's more there's
more stuff for us and of course as you
go up your options actually expand a lot
so you want to make sure you're right
making the right choice um can I ask you
guys a question you know how women
aren't really taught to be wives right
now do you think that men are taught how
to find a wife identify a wife no
no I don't think there's a teaching but
I think we all have like different forms
of like Role Models around us so the
females around us that example I've got
a like my sister she she got married
then had a had her children bought a
house with her husband and and and and
my mum same scenario I think we we all
whether it's our family or family
friends we see and we we know really
what we should be going for because I
think I think you like literally have to
sit down and talk about this stuff I
think that's like you know reasons for
the churches although it's not it's not
the best you know statistics for
marriage either but they literally sit
down and say like Hey by scripture this
is what a wife looks like but I think
that's how men are getting Bamboozled
it's like nobody like literally sits you
down I was like okay this is what a
virtuous woman looks like
the fatherless homes I think are
contributing to that because I think
your dad is supposed to teach you
because your mom will lie to you you
know but I think your dad will tell you
yeah there's identifiers and men look
for them all the time but the thing is
women aren't actually told what those
identifiers are until much later on and
also I actually think the solution is a
woman should actually start looking for
something serious a lot younger instead
of using her younger years to like test
the playing field or like go on dates
and stuff when she turns 18 I think she
should actually start considering
looking for something serious in L.A I
just think at the end of the day like
women are a roll of the dice I I
genuinely think like
you're just never gonna know for sure
and it's just it's just a risk but like
I understand with how bad the contract
is today like why they want to take so
much time seven years if you laugh for
me that's a bit too yeah seven years is
mud I'll be honest but the problem is as
well though I think obviously you always
mention that and if people always
mention taking half taking half taking
half we like we hear about it like a lot
and the kids and and obviously like the
kids in that situation but one thing is
a lot a lot of men have the fear of odd
woman's gonna take off I reckon about
half the men there's nothing for the
woman to even take half of so that's the
first thing no that's the that's the
realness though because if we really
look at it and everybody has there's a
trial balance
um and we're looking at what's really
there first and foremost there's not a
lot so one thing I'd I'll cut like from
my from my personal situation my
daughter's favorite
so I think yeah when I was 21.
so the first thing was like right I've
had her out of marriage so my first
thing was security what's the first
thing so I was thinking right what can I
do what can I do so for me it was about
securing
um for her security was to get a
property so then I was thinking okay
cool but now if I marry that's already
pre-marriage so as long as you sign it
then obviously whatever you have as a
marriage going forward then I split
that's what I think it's fair that's why
I could never be with someone that that
obviously the theme I'm not working for
me that's not really I need especially
nowadays she needs to be earning like a
like a 30k year 40K year just just to
keep things ticking because that's
expensive now I mean so I think yeah we
need to be put too much and we put too
much emphasis sometimes on the whole
taking taken of heart I actually think
that taking half and this is probably
unpopular I think it's worse for the
average guy than it is for Rich guys
because like I think of I think of my
dad if my mom took halfway he'd be fine
even if he had like maybe she took 80 of
his wealth like he's so productive that
he would just make more more and like
maybe not as much but he would be fine
but I think like the average guy takes
him 25 years to get to that point and
then she can also take half also on that
point if
if
um
I I let's say I had a wife we had we had
two kids uh a girl and a boy and for
whatever reason she wanted to get a
divorce
I I would I would want them to have half
maybe even three quarters I'm good I'm
all right like I'm gonna be good I just
I need what I need and I'm gonna be good
and I can get out there I can still do
whatever I would want them to have most
because not not for not necessarily for
my partner
but for my kids for sure I would want
them to have all of that well if she
takes the kids and doesn't let you see
them oh no no no that's not that's
impossible
she's paid to do it do you have kids my
brother no not kids no so that's why you
say that that's why it answers that but
yeah okay but I hear
what what is it there I forgot the
person that mad billionaire his wife got
half
that's the one I didn't know if you
could do name drops I thought I'd make
it big yeah but um yeah we've got half
but the situation and the point where
they got married the financial situation
was not that I feel like genuine I feel
like she was due that the problem is
it's like no but no but that's what
because we're talking about all these
things like loyalty and we're looking at
all of these lists and at the end of the
day she would have played a a role to to
enable him to do that yeah
but look at their wealth after the
marriage if she played that big of a
role she would have made more money
after they got married where he his his
wealth increased by like fifty percent
like I just think like there's a
difference between like your wife doing
your accounting versus really building
your business not 100 and 10 I think
yeah that's that's fact but
obviously the reason she got such a big
chunk was because at the point of
marriage to at the point of divorce I'm
sure there was like sporadic growth and
we can't there's all of these things
here she would really have had to
build up her man if she was the type of
person that all she was doing at home
was always testing build up a minute
you can Inspire him but I just I I grew
up around like Ultra Ultra successful
now they were going to be successful
whether or not they had a girl there but
earlier on we was talking about testing
now I in my opinion I don't think Jeff
Bezos would have built that massive if
all if Wes was at home always testing
testing testing like I just it's
possible Right but I feel that maybe not
a huge role but she would have played
her part in that and in and she was she
was looked after for that yeah it was a
ridiculous amount of money it was a
ridiculous amount she just got divorced
again from a school teacher yeah but you
know so okay I have a question for
everyone who raised your hand do you
think if a girl's with you for 20 years
she deserves half
I'm gonna do different percentages so
you say half you say up 20 years half
okay do you think she deserves
um 30 percent
of your wealth
off to 20 years and the people that
didn't say 50. 30 because she deserve
twenty percent twenty twenty percent you
give her 20. all right ten percent
but does anyone think zero percent
okay
does anyone think more than 50 percent
okay I just I'm just curious my
perspective is a little bit different I
mean like I am I am married I didn't
raise my hand
I mean this is my perspective so it's
very subjective
um so I can't imagine any reason that I
would get divorced I think it would have
to come down to something that's
absolutely uncontrollable like there's
nothing that I could think about at this
point in time you know maybe maybe
there's uh an addiction or maybe you
know there could be the death of a child
sometimes you just can't come back from
that but my thing about it is is like if
I had to had to outside of Mega control
get divorced I feel like I could sit
down over breakfast and have a
conversation because the intent is that
you don't marry you know like an a-hole
right you sit down and you say look I
don't think this relationship is viable
uh can I get your help for the next
three to six months how much do you
think you could do this is when I expect
I can get a job I feel like you can
negotiate I think women are too too
quick to go to the court over things
that you can really settle down over
breakfast but I I think it's the women
typically that don't want to be the an
adult in that situation and I think that
that's wrong yeah I think if she spent a
certain amount of time with you and
she's invested in you in your growth now
that might not be like you mentioned
about the Jeff Bezos thing he had
nothing really until he didn't have what
when he married her he didn't have
nothing to a certain degree to what he's
got now right so she's she's factored
into that to some degree of success now
that might not be from a business aspect
but it's from some of the things we've
mentioned here today on the board you
know peace support etc etc and I feel
like that is not a reward but almost
like a a uh like maybe a payout or just
like a compensation to some degree but
she has to but this is this goes back to
our point before of like this is why we
spend a lot of time vetting them to even
get the ring in the first place because
you want to feel like okay she's built
me up to a certain way where she yeah I
wouldn't feel too bad about giving her
half because she's been there from the
from the bottom and I'm like I'm a huge
believer in whatever you have before
marriage that's your that's his that's
hers I agree that that's what I believe
but whatever is after the marriage like
a decent and split but whatever's before
the marriage is is fully separate so
whatever happens beyond that I think
it's a fair split all right um raise of
hands do you think men should page do
you think men should pay child support
yes yes if you think yes it depends on
the context so if I know all the money's
going to the children yeah okay so oh
interesting so you yeah you mentioned so
100 100 of men okay interesting but is
that what you're saying just there it is
to me if I know if it's going to I don't
know then I'm paying for child myself
yeah I will pay the child myself
I think women are so so so dumb
sometimes because like let's say you had
you had a cool baby daddy right you guys
were chilling co-parenting whatever and
then you got this little little bug in
your ear talking about take him taking
the child support put him on child
support you know like that man might be
offended and give you less and he was
already going to be involved in the
child because he wants that kid but now
you as the woman you're going to get 300
or 500 a month you're stupid you could
have been getting like a couple Grand or
if you stayed in the relationship you
could have been getting all the
resources but uh yeah uh the married
woman did not raise her hand no child
support for me no yeah I just I just
don't know why we're paying girls to
leave yeah like that that's that's my my
like that's the way I think about it I'm
like where why does she get money I
didn't get pregnant yeah no money
I hear it it's not taking away
accountability but I think guys have
this innate like protection almost
towards women so I just think it's kind
of in guys I'd be more thinking about
the kids yeah you know you know how I
think we solve the child support
um problem
men should just get custody of the
children yeah and that's how many of you
think that you think men should
automatically get custody of the
children I mean
statistics
depends on the age of the kids okay
because they actually improve yeah
statistically like they'll keep the
sun's out of jails their daughter's off
the stripper pole I think there's a time
for mum and there's a age for that why
do you say no
um I say no because I would imagine I'd
pick a good woman to look after my child
and I'd still be involved so my
involvement is going to steer them in
the right direction so okay I'm gonna
Read Super chats because I haven't read
them in the show sorry guys I see you
guys blowing up the chat guys make sure
you like the video um the like is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
there's almost 2 000 people in here so
there should be 2 000 likes on the video
make sure you hit that like button okay
um Swiss um if she's not an asset she's
a burden um Philip holy mackerel Pearl
and Ally back together again let's go
KCF have you guys noticed how peaceful
and civilized Today's Show is when it's
a bunch of logical minded guys and
there's no emotional 304 is just saying
a 200 Super Chat around
um Tyler Tyler zika I'm choosing
choosing a month total for specific
relationship Milestones as a Fool's
errand chemistry and commitment is all
that matter waiting to have sex before
marriage no no corn no Fab is the only
way to show someone you are serious
about the marriage else you are just
exploiting each other from the start uh
Matt butcher it's all often the women
who have totally unreal expectations and
or trying to change the man after the
fact or they are just evil to begin with
Mr Dill agath if a marriage breaks up
and the judge grants 50-50 to custody
then there shouldn't be any child
support payment if the marriage laws
didn't punish men women wouldn't break
up a marriage Dario Duplin I know I'm
late but my older brother took seven
years before he married his wife they've
been together for 15 years now Tales
from um settle Ranch and engagement time
shouldn't be infinite since no man in
the U.S should marry it exposes you to
the worst emotional and financial
disaster possible megtow Doug MPA
feminism made it so men don't owe women
anything a man can take as long as he
wants to commit it's up to the woman to
leave if he's taking too long Matt
butcher a lady can easily put on an act
for six months to hook you when you
found out how psycho she is you will be
floored um amend Dana it if it takes
knowing all women to figure them out you
never will learn the one person you're
with and learn them just saying iconic
FPS men want someone to support them
would it not be relevant to lead by
example and remain monogamous for the
sake of leading by example Matt butcher
the multiple partners thing gets old and
is a lot to keep up with the best is one
partner and the best is one partner and
know how to get her to want sex Pearl
did you have trouble reading this LOL
shut up
um TJ Drummond 178 100 Super Chat thank
you Reginald Enterprises it's always the
top men but it was Men in your town now
that travel is easy it's it's become the
top men in the world 90 Frito pie
be righteous about saying no to sex
don't be Petty Matt Hugh I love your
message you're making change in here
healing the world speak we are listening
see Dumbledore if um guys either after
the wedding or after the first kid comes
it's all over dead bedroom is
practically guaranteed Russ Kristen H I
had all of that at one point I lost her
to the pursuit of a career 90 Frito pie
employees get to test because they won't
submit employees get to test because
they submit they trust each other women
hold the hostage to prove a point four
panel the last compliment four panel the
last compliment you've gotten
Rob Harmony
women should not Shack with a man she
doesn't respect if she doesn't respect
him she should be able to trust the
decision he makes as a man not trusting
a man as an excuse for a poor decision
making in women
um which cat bore I can't say that name
Pearl should be using the white more
more often
I'm not I don't want to read that one
Christian h no friends no social media
stop laughing blessings
um no no friends no social media same
religion smaller than myself by at least
50 to 40 percent fit motherly cute not
cute not hot Frugal girly loyal
respectful in public last but not least
less than three bodies a million dollar
girl Alistar Horton might answer peace
common goals support brutal honesty a
rational mind so you can make decisions
in my absence reducing my workload at
home and a second opinion when necessary
and comforting see Dumbledore can we
please stop saying I can only speak for
me unless you're an ambassador or
Minister it's a given that you're only
speaking for yourself Jason ghost um
start the collection play at the church
is it the church is in service fiber
keep up the great content and thank you
for giving voice to discussions that are
ignored Okay so
so going with the topic what should
women bring to the table
I'm going to read some advice from the
19 I think it's 20s or 30s
um and we're going to see if you guys
think this is good advice
how to land him so how to how to get you
a man
show and show him you can have fun on a
cheap date but don't overdo it
yeah yeah
okay don't let your parents treat him
like a treat to him like a potential
husband
um what what I'm just reading I'm this
is ask your parents to disappear when
you're entertaining double date with a
gay happily married couple let him see
what it's like
um
hell no tell his friends nice things
about him
yeah hype your man up um send his mother
a birthday card yes ask his mother for
her recipes yes definitely talk to his
father about business and agree that
taxes are too long okay you know what
that sounds like a great Pro tip
actually
the taxes aren't you yeah I mean that's
funny
um by his sister's children an
occasional present yeah yeah do that on
a first date tell him you aren't
thinking of getting married
okay so he doesn't feel the pressure
that's a weird advice for them
I'm just saying good advice or bad
advice
first day talking about will you marry
me like maybe the third one don't talk
about how many children you want
to see what's wrong no that's actually
quite important one yeah okay if he's a
fisherman learn to scale and clean fish
yes yes oh that's interesting don't
don't tell him everything about yourself
at the start hold something in reserve
yes yeah when you're out strolling with
him don't insist on stopping at every
shop window yes please I disagree please
don't tell him how much your clothes
cost
yes learn to sew learn to sew oh I'm
interested because 22-22 learn to sew
and wear something you've made yourself
yes
a lot yes learn to solve I want to see
Patrick sewn into my trousers don't
gossip about him
oh this is interesting never let him
know he's the only one even if you have
to stay home one or two nights a week
what the hell well this is what you're
recording right yeah yeah what do you
guys think no no
definitely need to know if I don't know
I am not doing anything serious
that's the worst thing I've ever had in
my life well I think back then maybe
they weren't sleeping with more than one
person no no yeah yeah there's a
difference back then they weren't
sleeping yeah you could go on multiple
dates with men without sleeping with
them and I think like women should do
that but they don't but they don't
they'll bang on the first day so it's
like if a woman makes a guy think that
he's not the only one he'll run away she
will decide that she will never be she
she's joining the broadcast Recreation
don't um don't be a pushover when he's
trying to make a date
that's terrible advice that's terrible
advice all right very early in your
dating why not get a favorite song that
you both regard as your own I also start
to like it's like your song that's cute
yeah it's like a shoe collection find
out about the oh
this is actually good advice find out
about the girls he hasn't married don't
repeat the mistakes they made
that would be useful don't discuss your
former boyfriends yeah yes don't have
any if you are widowed or divorced don't
constantly discuss your former husband
same thing be flexible if you just got
if he decides to skip the dance and go
rowing on the lake go even if you were
wearing your best evening gown yeah I
agree with that have fun yep hi hide
your Phi Beta Kappa key if you own one
later on Junior later on Junior can play
with it what's up so it's a sorority key
what does that mean what is that that's
a U.S one I don't know turn wolves into
husband material by assuming they have
honor
turn wolves oh so you're saying like
turn the bad boy into a husband but like
basically assuming he has honor so like
treating him I assume the best in him
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it's
possible yeah why do you hesitating I
don't know it's just like the it's not
easy for a guy to be swayed like that I
think it takes a bit more than just
honoring the guy
because when you when you do that to a
guy who's not in a position to want to
when you do that to a bad guy a wolf in
that case you just get you're just
leaving yourself open to be taken
advantage of in my opinion you know how
they say you can't turn a hole into a
housewife why are you trying to turn a
bad boy into a house exactly he will do
it on his own time when he's ready women
think they can fix men in that regard
yeah you can't listen listen by the way
the the the the advice was saying the
woman should assume he has honor and
will switch up his ways to for the right
word oh yes oh yeah it's a it's a mental
thing they're saying like don't assume
he's like don't assume he's a wolf or
else that's what you're gonna see and I
think this is possible yeah that that's
definitely possible yeah I know guys who
would change up entirely if they met the
right girl tomorrow so that's that's
definitely the case learn where to draw
the line but do it gracefully um yes
remain Innocent but not ignorant yeah oh
my God these are amazing make your home
comfortable when he calls large ashtrays
comfortable chairs
learn learn to play poker machine
man if he's Rich tell him you like his
money the honesty will Intrigue him Matt
nah
I think that that's like I don't think
there's nothing I don't think there's
nothing wrong with that like woman uh
women are hard wired women are
hard-wired I expect men to provide so
she's attracted to a man that's rich
yeah but I like your money I don't think
a man's trying to hear no because I
don't think it's like you'll leave if he
loses the money no no I don't think it's
like that like men don't want to feel
like they're going to work for nothing
no no because you could be like babe
thank you so much for going to work I
really appreciate what you're
contributing to the household it means
the world to me you know like let him
know that you like that he's gainfully
employed
if it said you didn't meant if it said
tell him you like his money but say it
gracefully
you're telling him but listen I love how
much money
I love the house okay whatever what
about you what about you're such a
hard-working man oh yeah the thing is by
saying it by saying it like that you're
respecting his work ethic Yeah by saying
it like that I like your bread and it's
nice that's not what he's trying to
that's not what that's not what he's
trying to hear no no never let him
believe oh this is never let him believe
your career is more important to you
than marriage
bye or buy him an amusing or
particularly appropriate present every
once in a while but don't make it too
expensive yes
I like cheap funny gifts clip and mail
him a funny cartoon that means something
to both of you and don't tell dirty
stories whatever it's a thoughtful gift
I think yeah that's the point is do do
something again
stop being a mama's girl don't let him
think he'll have trouble with his mother
don't think let him think he'll have
in-law trouble even if you know he will
oh this one is so funny because last one
is so funny okay
point
out to him that the death rate of single
men is twice that of married man
what do we think all these good so far
more hits a few misses okay wait I have
one more article I was gonna read and
then today's women I'll tell you I feel
like the first I feel like the first
half sounded like it come from a place a
lot of things come from a place of
respect I found that I mean it got a bit
left after but I feel definitely feel
like the first batch was definitely a
place of respect lures you in and then
when you're talking about like get like
a little bit of um like a gift for
what was it like the for his his nieces
yeah like I feel like you're showing
that you want to be integrated into his
family is showing intention yeah and and
that's that's all that people are trying
to see now
okay so I have one more so this is
nine tips for taking care of your
husband taken from a 1950s home economic
book
have dinner ready plan ahead even the
night before to have a delicious meal on
time this is a way of letting him know
that you have been thinking about him
and are concerned about his needs most
men are hungry when they come home and
the prospect of a good meal are part of
the warm welcome needed amen how to be a
watch 101 yeah this means no and then
it's like the after it's the in modern
turns okay moms this means no last
minute Frozen nuggets chucked onto an
oven tray after the daycare is picked up
dinner needs to be thoughtfully planned
ahead of time and don't even think for a
second this isn't your job yes 100 too
prepare yourself take 15 minutes to rest
so you will look refreshed when he
arrives touch up your makeup put a
little ribbon on your hair and be fresh
looking he has just been with a lot of
work weary people be a little gay and a
little more interesting his boring day
may need a lisp lit Li lift wipe that
I'm so over it Mom face right off the
second he doesn't want to see that he's
weary he's tired and I think they're
trying to be sarcastic but I feel like
this is speaking facts he's weary he's
tired you are not and no you didn't have
a day at work either just tell the kids
that you need 15 minutes of me time to
go get ready for Daddy's arrival of
course he'll understand oh and don't
forget to change out that out of that
top smells of spew oh you see they're
trying to be sarcastic but I feel like
it's facts this is 1950s
yeah well it's like the the first half
is like the from the 50s and then like
it's the response of modern woman today
basically I think
um listen I think if you if your Mrs is
at home
doing all of those things
that it that is work it you know it's
not that's not light it's not easy right
you know that is something to be
respected and valued yeah I'd say a 10
minute touch up is not that deep though
yeah I mean I mean I'm not yeah okay
what but but still it's it's an effort
she's she's making an effort to look
after herself so that you can come in
and receive this you know this this
effort that she's made but not not only
that but the other things you know don't
just throw chicken wings in the in the
oven but actually plan the meal prepare
the meal someone else was talking uh
earlier on on the part about
um having a nice clean house to come
back to so if she's doing all of those
that's work that is that is you know
what the difference is though at the
time of at the time when women were at
home
and they weren't in the workforce they
were getting compensated by men
providing for everything yeah exactly
and obviously now that women are in the
workforce
they want men to provide the same way
but they're working yeah but it's the
lifestyle a lot of times women want like
a guy can pay for an apartment
exactly it's true
um okay so the number three clear away
the Clutter make one last trip through
the main part of the house just before
your husband arrives Gathering up school
books toys paper then run a dust cloth
over the tables your husband will feel
he has reached a Haven of Rest and order
and it will give you a lift too now this
is the response from the Modern Woman
yes a Haven of Rest and order do not
lose your [ __ ] at him for fidgeting
flinging his shoes off in the middle of
the living room again right after you've
decluttered and yelled at the kids for
never cleaning up their toys again and
this is your job do it without complaint
what okay first of all your husband your
husband leaving his shoes on the floor
is not the same as your kids leaving
around toys okay this is like the leader
of your household in the provider uh can
you can you what did she say again
um
do not lose your [ __ ] at him for
flinging his shoes off in the middle of
the living room again right after you've
decluttered and yelled the kids for
never cleaning up their toys again this
is your job do it without complaining no
no I got it I got it because this is the
thing like it's about perspective I get
women get frustrated but if your man was
to die tomorrow you'd be like damn I
wish he could throw his shoes in the
living room floor one more time like be
grateful uh you know like I left I left
my my house for four weeks I came back
and it was messy and I thought it was
gonna be mad because that's what you see
everywhere on TV and I was like oh my
goodness I'm essential he needs me
that's a good attitude to have yes it
really is if only every woman saw it
like that
I get to pick up your shoes yeah I know
I get excited and you know to be real
though if it's like an hour before your
man is coming home I'm a house if I
don't have any kids yet but you know the
hour beforehand you do kind of naturally
go around the house and try to pick up
some things so he doesn't come home to
hell I don't get it this is such a
standard basic thing it just should be
the base should be the minimum but I
don't I don't work though so it's like
different yeah that's what I was about
to say that's where it's not working
that should be the bare minimum but
that's like the shift so you've got some
people wanting that the female amount to
earn the money but at the same time
wants the female to do all the cooking
and all the cleaning no I think that's
weird I think it's only
if she's also not working so if you're
doing everything then I think it is
absolutely 100 her duty to do everything
at home clean
if she's also working I personally don't
have anything to say on that because I
just wouldn't be interested in that so
in that case I would want the situation
to be where she's taking care of the
house entirely on her own I come home to
just absolute peace and Clarity but I
don't I don't know what it would be like
if she was also working because then
it's just like you know it's automated
nowadays it's not like you don't have to
spend three hours on a meal like you
used to when you say it like you don't
gotta churn butter like stop it
it's not that and and the thing is guys
have to fix [ __ ] around the house if
something breaks who fixes it when you
say like guys guys have different roles
and our shit's all automated washing
machine
yeah dishwasher like the woman who wants
to work even though like financially she
could stay home and take care of her
kids because some women are only netting
like 500 a month like when you subtract
child care so it's like I think a lot of
times women are conditioned to be
workers and they they choose to take the
L they don't know that it's an L but
they're they're making that option yeah
but also it's about having the option as
well I think that sometimes when we say
oh like we'd love to be in a position
where you don't have to work they take
it as like oh I have to be at home or
you can have to be barefoot and pregnant
this is no what do you like the options
I
think the women that push back on that
subconscious you don't want men to be in
control yeah yes yeah and that comes
down to trust that yeah a lot of it
comes down to trust as well
four prepare the children take a few
minutes to wash the children's hands and
faces if they are small comb their hair
and if necessary change their clothes
they are little treasures and he would
like to see them playing the part now
this is the response from the Modern
Woman yes do rummage through the washing
baskets and find clean clothes for your
little Treasures who have morphed into
monsters coming Witching Hour which is
right about the time he's due home and
resists leaving them grubby until bath
time he is not going to appreciate that
look at how miserable they are
misery and I'm like why why are the
clean clothes in the basket that's my
that was my thought of myself
zero organizations everything everything
that sounds like a chore to them to more
than women it's not much it's like more
than women don't want to be mothers like
no I agree and they feel like they're I
mean I don't I think they're just
ignorant it's not like your kids don't
have access to the internet all these
angry moms on Tick Tock they're gonna
make them feel like crap if they realize
how much you resent them but I think
that Sometimes women only think about
themselves but I think you know clean
the kids if you can all right like you
know they're little sometimes they get
into stuff just get a wet wiper to clean
it yeah
and you can't it's not it's not it's not
sexy you know I'd rather be taking Snaps
on for insta right now or in a bikini
doing some twerking videos right now
that's the thing that's I'm missing out
on doing that my friends are doing it
everyone else is doing it I don't want
to be looking after my kids and wiping
their faces in Dubai that's not sexy man
I want to be yeah I want to be on that
boat do you know what to be to be fair
to women yeah being in a traditional
housewife and working at the same time
is difficult and I think as men
like men know how difficult it is to be
a traditional woman which men genuinely
want men genuinely want their women to
still have Traditional Values but when
women are presenting this boss [ __ ]
it's in conflict with you being a
functional mother and wife
stay away from God
minimize all nor minimize all noise at
the time of his or his or I can't talk
at the time of his arrival eliminate all
noise of washer dryer dishwasher or
vacuum try to encourage the children to
be quiet be happy to see him greet him
with a warm smile and be glad to see him
now this is the response don't forget to
give the kids this memo oh and flicking
on the Telly for a bit of shush isn't
encouraged what if the PAW Patrol theme
songs annoy him just ask the kids to be
quiet and still easy I mean I don't
agree with the modern woman take no but
but I am going to say like I think
that's OD like I don't think my husband
cares if the dishwasher's on the washer
dries he's not that kind of guy I just
feel like he wouldn't care like what
type of man you know is gonna be like
actually babe all the machines got to be
off that's a specific kind of guy I
think this is in response to 1950s back
then those machines were very loud okay
yeah so that's why he's talking about it
obviously today everything's silent yeah
the message is he wants to just come
home to it silent home nice is that what
you were saying yes outside is the case
we want to come home
I don't think a washing machine being
noisy at home is is chaos well you see
when when men hear chaos it's just like
arguing like I don't feel yeah I don't
think a man if a man's seen his clothes
getting washing the machine and it's
making a bit of noise I don't think a
man's complaining I don't think you've
heard those 1950 machines
if three of them are going off at once
it sounds like a warzo and I'm sure as
well back in the 1950s a lot of the jobs
were manual noisy laborious so coming
home into a place where it's a bit just
clean because it's a cool Serena I I
understand it but now it's it's not
really a problem half the machines I
probably don't even know it's on yeah
literally you can get like silent
machines
washing machines now yeah and I guess if
she is a housewife and she's been at
home all day she could do that stuff
before so you have free time together
when you get back as well some don't
number six so it's gonna tell us what
not to do don't greet him with problems
or complaints don't complain if he's
late for dinner count this as a minor
compared with what he might have gone
through that day
now this is the response yes yes do not
annoy him with stories of how you
juggled two little ones with gastro
today while also having to work from
home because they couldn't go to daycare
oh and now you can also feel your tummy
starting to growl again he doesn't want
to hear it
I think this entire article is women
complaining about being married to men
that aren't that fast work for them to
stay home no no I think it's like not
every guy can afford for you to stay
home so like you're going to have to
work Point Blank period the end so this
whole this entire article I'm like baby
girl you better compete for the high
value band yeah you better compete do
something I don't know it's like Deborah
lose the 50 pounds
you know this girl is not skinny you
know I don't even know what she looks
like okay seven make him feel
comfortable have him lean back in a
comfortable chair or suggest he lie down
in the bedroom have a cool or warm drink
ready for him and arrange his pillow and
offer to take off his shoes speak in a
low soft soothe and pleasant voice allow
him to relax and unwind
response sounds like a dream
moms this means no shouting mom rage
even if there's no one listening to you
and your man is looking at his phone
instead of the full-blown sibling fight
that is happening before his very eyes
no just keep him call calm allow him to
relax you don't need a drink he does
this is very aggressive like she's just
they come across like no I am on Vines
button activate like you know some of
the girl that took off my man's shoes
yeah he must be mad
take off take off his own shoes
yeah would you would you guys like that
if a girl said sit down take your shoes
off yes please different so feminine to
do that as well remember Coming to
America are you gonna do that
no I I tried it so he's just not into
that like he's very he wants to I've
offered he wants to take off his own
boots but to be honest so they're
military boots they don't really smell
the best so I'm glad he was like no
thank you no thank you
um eight listen to him
you may have a lot of things to tell him
but the moment of his arrival is not
that time let him talk first
oh shut up all right
again he doesn't care about your day or
that your boss is a jerk or that his
baby needs a change right now you've got
risotto on the stove that needs stirring
or that his pride and joy firstborn
dropping the F-bomb at preschool today
just zip it Zip Zip
Scrolls a lot of preschool he's already
dropping that I think this is peach mom
from Twitter I don't know if you guys
remember that this lady went viral for
making cartoons about how much she
resents her husband but she doesn't
think that they're offensive cartoons at
all at all
now last one make the evening his
never complain if he does not take you
out to dinner or other places of
entertainment Instead try to understand
his world of strain and pressure he
needs to come home and relax
response yep we've got it he's had a
hard day his Barista Coffee that he got
to drink without having to microwave 10
times over and didn't have the Two
Sugars he asked for and when he got into
the office kitchen that was out of sugar
he didn't have the time to he didn't
take time he didn't have time to return
to the cafe because someone in the
office had a birthday that he had to
stay out and eat cake
they're very specific this one okay so
so now she is apparently married to a
high value man and still complaining I
guess whatever author was inspired by
this but you know what it is this is
interesting it's because like women
don't want men who make the same amount
of money or less than them right so he
goes and he earns more and that probably
means that he has like a higher
demanding job than you and so it would
make sense that he might incur more
stress and then want more peace at home
but then they're they're still
complaining but they won't date like the
broke guy so I'm just I don't think
women really know what they want I don't
know I think women will always find
something to complain about yeah
they'll actually go out of their way to
find something to complain about because
if everything's going well then they
start to like what's going on why is
everything going well something's wrong
right now so what do you guys think of
the dating advice from the 1950s how'd
it sound some of it had some really key
valuable points which I think some
Modern women if they took half of this
they'd be able to get a man should we
implement this in wife's school oh yeah
if you did that people were getting
married it'll be like how long can we
keep quiet what's that timer is
do it that'd be a good episode that'd be
hard for me too we need to start selling
toys when to play with like fidgeting
toys so they can just keep quiet
learn to read again the last name oh yes
how long can you go without social media
the last statement was the same the guy
never takes his wife out
no she doesn't complain when he doesn't
don't complain if he doesn't all I ever
think you out never complain if he does
not take you out to dinner or other
places of entertainment you don't need
to complain you can just ask hey honey I
feel like I haven't gone on a date in a
while diving that's something we could
do this weekend you don't need to
complain yeah it's about I think the
best about the delivery as well so it's
not the stuff you're saying no if you
come across in like a feminine way and
and you cooperate and correct and it's
it's not a thing a respectful way the
guy will actually want to I can't even
imagine like you haven't taken me out on
a date in a while and honestly I just I
don't appreciate it I feel like I'm
being neglected this just sucks like I'd
responded I'm not going to
it's all about just compromising
communication to some degree right yes
tonality is very very important like men
really take on tonality of how you speak
to us like we mentioned earlier about
respect and all these things a lot of it
because a man couldn't talk to me a
certain way with that bass in his voice
so Natalie you think it's not gonna
happen because with men there's always
that undefended underlying threat of
violence it's not that little women the
women sometimes think they can act Wild
and we're just going to take it it's
like no disrespected to suspect
are you entitled to being taken on a
date by a husband
no I don't think I'm entitled I think he
wants to take me out it's typically he's
the one trying to go out I'm always
trying to stay home I'm like we have
food at home he's like oh come on let's
go have fun
cool
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats one more
time and then we're gonna do final
thoughts um this was a fun panel I
learned a lot actually I feel like I
learned a lot listening to like
What Men actually want so
um okay so guys we gotta find the tab
guys make sure you're liking the video
um
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these live
streams so make sure you like a like is
free um also all super chats
um blessing what are we saving for now
we bought the 8K camera
what should we say for
uh how many more cameras you want
okay blessing wants three more cameras
how much do we need to raise for three
more cameras
okay 8K okay so the super chats you know
next month we're trying to get to 8K um
to get him three more cameras so Denise
um booed Ronnie um thank you for the
super chat um
zero next
um all right it would be good to go over
jobs working class women used to do
before and during the first wave
suffragettes time because women have
always worked also the hatred towards
the 1950 makes no sense and the U.S does
anyone not know that mini skirts are
tied to the flampers of the Roaring 20s
Tales From SLV Ranch amusing story for a
joke a friend once did the entire entire
list for her husband at the end he said
where's the bow be referring to the bow
in her hair Vlad storen if both are
working share if both are working share
the workload basic communication and
compromise silly sausage they want to be
the prize but end up turning themselves
into a participation trophy
um
Mr dilgath what if a man puts her
through school buys their house without
her help does she then deserve half
that's a good question
Lawrence Bullock if a woman divorce if a
woman divorces because she says I work
too much or she cheated then doesn't
then she doesn't deserve anything except
child support if we have kids
90 free-toe pay for the panel do you
find yourself dating in your race more
than others have your parents influenced
that choice in any way does it make a
difference in any way K to the Swiss if
she's not an asset she's a burden I'm
Philip Sadiq holy mackerel Pearl and
Ally back together again
um oh I think I read all these let me
just refresh it really quick to make
sure I didn't miss any
um like the video guys like the video
um okay Mr Dill
um Dilla Gaff um widowed father here
after my marriage and the ish I did and
apparently didn't do I'm super picky
this time around okay so final thoughts
start with Ali go around and then second
row
good I think
we need to keep talking to him and ask
them about what they want but men also
y'all need to give specifics we need
Specific Instructions we need to know
um but yeah thank you for having me and
I hope I I gave some of y'all hope at
least I'm telling you there's women out
there that like sleeping with their
husband and like staying home it's just
not most of them but that's just because
they haven't figured out how much of a
dub that is so that's kind of like their
fault that's what I would say
yeah I had a great time hey it's good to
hear a lot of um different guys talk
about stuff that matters I thought was
the only one which is which is great
um yeah and really really happy to be
here and yeah drop me a follow your
hostel
um likewise I thought this was a good
discussion um good points made
especially like for women who are
looking to be a housewife
um another point I just want to stress
for like guys
um you can't expect these things if
you're like a bum I feel like a lot of
guys can be deluded sometimes to think
to expect and all this and you really
have nothing to give yourself so that's
just a reminder for those guys like
don't be delusional as well
so yeah I just want to say a big thank
you to Pearl for bringing me back on the
show um it was good being here it was a
good panel was agreed um yeah uh in
terms of the show my final thoughts it
was a good discussion it's always good
to have a a group of guys discussing
these things because obviously it's not
every day that you have these type of
conversations so yeah it was very
enlightened and good to hear other
people's opinions
oh yeah thanks for having me as well it
was good to be able to actually discuss
these sort of things I mean a lot of
these things you can't actually discuss
openly most of the time they actually
are things that people think and they
don't actually articulate in person or
they don't actually like saying out loud
but having a space like this actually
lets men in particular say what they
actually want and what they expect from
without the backlash without the
immediate backlash that will stop them
and there's no shaming here either so
that's the main thing that actually
allows it to flourish
yeah um thank you pal for obviously the
great platform
um it was good to have a conversation
here the perspective from women men
husbands wives of lack and I think yeah
it's just good to hear what men say and
even though we can disagree we can
disagree respectfully and still
understand each other's point of view So
yeah thank you
yeah it was great to be here with
everyone thank you uh for having me on
uh go and check out 100 interviews on
YouTube where I speak to interesting
people
um I've enjoyed everyone's um kind of
views and discussion here today
um my final thoughts
um I think it's a shame how Society
in terms of dating and relationships has
changed and continues to change and I
don't see it kind of reversing into like
a healthier position because of how
feminism is moving I don't think women
are ever going to want to go back to how
things were and I think with the rise of
feminism and social media and the
correlation between the two there are
good things that come with that and also
a lot of negative things that come with
that which is which is what I I think is
a shame but um you know for the small
percentage of women who still
um are looking for that real you know
real love uh that real man
um you know this is for you guys to kind
of get a pen and paper and take notes
and look to self-improve and develop
um yeah appreciate you for the platform
it's been refreshing um speaking about
everything with you guys I think that
sometimes that
when certain things aren't discussed
we're just going over Blurred Lines and
I think that males need to discuss
certain things more females need to be
more open and stop listening to the
single single friends
um but across the board yeah I think
it's been it's been a really good point
um and yeah really good points have been
made so and I appreciate it appreciate
you all
yeah thank you guys all for coming I
appreciate a lot of you guys came last
minute because we're between recruiters
this week so I really appreciate that
um okay guys a couple announcements
before we end the show um the first is
that we have two clips channels I need
you guys to go subscribe to both it's
just pearly clips and pearl daily um the
second thing is guys guys sign up for my
memberships the first here you get to be
a part of all of the live show chats the
second tier you get to be a part of our
Discord and behind the scenes Vlogs
we're going to be doing a penthouse tour
soon third tier where you connect with
us on social media fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
guys I really recommend this if you want
to grow on YouTube I can help you avoid
a lot of mistakes that I made early on
and save you a lot of time I promise to
God you will save so much time
um Instagram go follow it just dot
pearly things you have to type out the
whole thing because I am Shadow band on
Instagram I think I'm at 75 or 73k so
I'm trying to get to 100K that's my new
goal
um I'm gonna be doing like lifestyle
type um pictures on there so
um if I go like four-wheeling or
something I'm gonna take a picture uh
the second thing or the last thing is my
Tick Tock go follow my
fifth Tick Tock account just
pearlythings.5 and just probably think
six in case that one gets banned I
always have two just in case
um also guys thank you for 600k
um I think we're at 630k we hit that
like so quick so thank you guys so much
for that DM me if you want to come on
the show this week I think we need
guests for tomorrow and Saturday so DM
me if you want to come on like the video
on your way out and we will talk to you
next time
foreign